so we are all waiting patiently for the
supreme court to issue their ruling on
roe and casey as well as bruins so we
could see gun rights expand and we could
also see roe v wade overturned as well
as planned parenthood v casey and
we're waiting patiently because every
week they keep saying monday is opinion
day it's gonna happen and then nothing
happens and they're like well it could
be wednesday and then nothing happens
and then they're like well there's one
more week and then it's tuesday cause
juneteenth was celebrated yesterday then
they're like well maybe it's gonna be
thursday
and then they're like well
maybe it'll be the week after that and
it feels like they're just dragging it
out
probably to desensitize us from the
story because
it's gonna get overturned and people are
gonna lose their minds we have this far
left terror organization called jane's
revenge maybe i'm being a little too
generous in calling them an organization
but flyers have started to pop up all
over dc threatening
terrorism
look i'm not going to play the game the
media plays they're threatening violence
and riots but we know what it is it is
violence as a threat to sway political
opinion these people ruth sent us are
showing up in front of supreme court
justices homes and a man just tried to
kill a sitting supreme court justice
they are doing everything they can to
try and stop this from getting
overturned
short of actually
caught well i should say i shouldn't say
short of they caught the guy who's
trying to kill kavanaugh so it seems
like yeah they're doing everything they
can
in the event it gets overturned jane's
revenge says there will be violence the
gop has called on the federal government
the dhs and the fbi to label this group
a domestic terror organization i don't
think the federal government actually
does that
and the fbi says they are investigating
some 20-plus pro-life centers or
politicians who have been attacked had
their offices attacked vandalized or
even fire bombed in some instances so uh
you know it's getting pretty spicy out
there and just thinking about what's
been going on the past several years i
think a lot of people don't realize how
insane things are if i were to tell you
four years ago
that in four years
the supreme court would be on the verge
of overturning roe v wade and casey and
a far left group will be threatening to
burn down pregnancy centers commit acts
of violence against people and someone
would try to kill a sitting supreme
court justice you'd have told me i was
nuts there's no way that's going to
happen
and here we are
just i i just i really encourage people
can you can you find a video of yourself
from 2018 just like watch it and try and
remember what you were thinking back
then because i think we are frogs in the
pot
frogs in a pot and the water is starting
to boil it's getting nuts so we'll talk
about that we've also got the economy i
really want to talk about this uh the
potential for gun rights expansion
with the um
the new york case bruin uh where
they could potentially rule on uh
concealed carry
i think it's a one in a million chance
they go broad with it but the general
idea is they might require these
democrat states to issue concealed carry
permits at the bare minimum and we think
that's where it's going so we'll talk
about that we've got some uh hilarity uh
gop i think what's it was it was it
michigan i can't remember what it was no
no pennsylvania i think
where they took this gun control bill
and just copied and pasted
constitutional carry over it as a way to
defeat the bill it was brilliant so
we'll talk about that plus economy war
international conflict all that stuff
joe biden is here and joining us to talk
about all of this is larry sharpe
i'm here thank you for having me you
want to pull your mic up a little bit is
that good is it better there you go
so i'm here yes thank you so much for
having me who are you and what are you
doing i am a very handsome man who all
right okay yes
and and and also humble of all my traits
my modesty is second to none there's no
doubt about that but yes no i'm running
for governor of new york as a
libertarian still it's like i keep
punishing myself my second time around
and i'm happy to be here thanks right on
cool we got sheamus i'm seamus coughlin
on our youtube channel called freedom
tunes if you all go on to go over there
and check that out we'll be releasing a
cartoon thursday just released one this
past thursday i think you'll enjoy and
we launched a website freedomtunes.com
if you want to go over there become a
member you'll get an extra cartoon each
week and you'll be supporting good
independent content hi everyone ian
crossland here realistically optimistic
but who i'm sweating uh spiritually
right now so let's get down to talking
about it well i love larry because he's
always super upbeat but he's a very
realistic outlook on the world so i
think this is just what the doctor
ordered ian let's get rolling before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support our work as a member you'll get
access to our exclusive segments from
this show
monday through thursday at 11 pm they go
up every monday through thursday on the
website they're not family friendly they
are uncensored we swear a lot don't let
your kids listen but it's a it's good
fun and um you'll also be supporting our
journalists we just hired a couple more
we're going to be expanding into
documentaries we've had some meetings in
the documentaries we're going to be
doing gun control the federal reserve
it's going to be really really amazing
plus many many more to come we've got
more shows we're launching man expansion
is happening it's all thanks to you so
if you like the work we do if you think
there should be more of it go to
timcast.com become a member and also
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel right now
share this stream this live stream take
that url post it everywhere because
grassroots marketing is the most
powerful way to help spread the word and
help our help us you know grow the
mission that being said let's jump over
into that first story we got this one
from the independent
jane's revenge group appears to threaten
violence if supreme court overturns roe
a flyer is calling for a knight of rage
i gotta put anonymite in washington d.c
when the supreme court decision on roe
is handed down
i chose this source the independent
because they're like left-leaning and i
think it's funny that they're saying it
appears they're threatening violence
when they're outright saying you told us
you would riot
the militant abortion rights
organization change revenge appears to
be calling for a night of rage
in the nation's capital should the
supreme court as is expected overturn
roe v wade later this month this is the
organization that's already taken credit
for the vandalism and i'm not sure
did they did they take credit for the
firebombings jameis let me look up that
let me let me look that up so we've had
now what it's like 20 plus either
pro-life politicians or pregnancy
centers get vandalized windows smashed
out and some were firebombed more than
one this is the organization's taking
credit for some of these acts of terror
they're threatening war you combine that
with the showing up in front of the
supreme court justices homes you combine
that with the trying to take the life of
a sitting supreme court justice and i
mean we've just been watching extreme
violence over the past several years and
i gotta say
it really does feel like things are
crazier than they've been in a very long
time yeah 100 i completely agree i think
that the the worst part about this is
it doesn't work
so all it does is dig people deeper into
their own someone doesn't see that and
go oh they're firebombing well you know
what now i'm on your side no nobody does
that it just creates more violence it
dehumanizes the other it validates
violence as a as a way of feeling good
about your issue if you're really upset
about this and i get if you are i
understand that that viewpoint then
simply go to your state and have your
state make sure that you can have legal
and safe abortion in your state that's
the actual answer if you care so much
but i'll i'll counter with this please
violence doesn't work
in terms of trying to get support for
your cause and win win for your cause
but if you're trying to destabilize the
country to burn it down yeah see what
happens is i've been doing a lot of
reading about bleeding kansas and that's
you know some people are comparing
what's happening now to bleeding kansas
it was basically a statewide civil war
in the territory of kansas just it ended
because the civil war started so it
basically from 1854 until 1861 you had
this period of civil war but in kansas
pro-slavery groups and free-staters
fighting and killing each other
john brown who was you know
rose to notoriety uh due to bleeding
kansas sure was angry that abolitionists
were pacifists he didn't care to
persuade anyone he just straight walked
up to slave owners and blasted just
killed him killed five just walked up to
people with his kids started killing
people he did not care if anyone agreed
with him or not he said i'm done what
ends up happening is this causes an
escalation on the other side
so if your goal is to win for your cause
because you're hoping a stable country
will say
we voted for this and now this rule will
be enacted that's a terrible idea right
this jane's revenge stuff the only the
only thing i can see is the outcome is
going to be the inverse of what they
presumably want
people on the other side are going to
counter it but that will likely just
lead to destabilization and more
violence yeah i think but the other
issue is right if if you're on the side
what media are you listening to and
watching if you're watching media that
says well this is in reaction to if
that's the media you're hearing then it
sounds like it's almost reasonable see
it's an attack on us so we're being
aggressive to defend against the bad
people who are trying to hurt us so i'm
not sure that it actually turns their
side off if anything it just makes us to
your point it makes both people both
sides dig in harder and it hurts
anywhere in the middle because now if i
say hey
stop the violence
the right goes to me well they're
killing us and the left goes well
they'll kill they're killing us you're a
bad guy so now i don't hate one side or
the other so no i'm the bad guy too it
actually is what it wants to doing is
stifling
the calm person the person says can we
can't we you all get along it that
disciples that person sheamus did you
did you yeah so jane's revenge has taken
credit for various firebombings of wow
yeah yes from whatever the fbi says
they're investigating yeah the gop has
demanded that they get labeled a
domestic terror organization but i don't
think the federal government actually
labels domestic terror organizations i
don't know if that's a thing you had a
lot of people on the right saying antifa
should be and people on the left saying
like the clan or the right-wing group
should be and the government's like we
don't label groups we label actions like
we're criminal actions or not
i don't see de-escalation coming i've
been saying this for a long time
uh you know in the intro to the show
i pointed out
four years ago five years ago maybe even
three years ago if i went to you and
said in three years time a a far leftist
would attempt to assassinate a sitting
supreme court justice because the court
because for the first time in history a
draft opinion had been leaked showing
that roey wade roe v wade and planned
parenthood vk was going to be overturned
people were showing him in the streets
firebombing buildings you'd be like no
way you know what though people told me
that was never going to happen the part
of that that would surprise me the most
was the possibility of roe v wade being
overturned
exactly yeah
the fact that the left would react
violently is not something i think that
whatever but this this has to be you
know this has to be slowly ex accepted
and it has become right since the the
the recent violence in the streets right
this has become more acceptable as
normal right if you and i'll give you a
good example uh historical one if it's a
1912 1913 germany
and if you were to say to someone hey
you know what 30 years from now you
germans will be systematically er you
know rounding up all your jewish
population and murdering them all
they've been like stop we're germany we
would never do that
come on stop yet 30 years later they're
doing it and if you were born if you
were born at that time
if you're a young woman a young man born
in say 1910 1912 in germany you would
have never thought to do such a thing it
would have taken years for me to be
brainwashed enough to do nothing right
to not be involved but just let it
happen and be like well yeah i guess
they kind of deserve it because they're
the bad guys this guy hitler said and i
think we're finding a similar thing
again my point is they're the bad guys
so it's okay remember people who do bad
things always validate their bad
behavior they don't think they're doing
bad things they validate it somehow
exactly right no group of people who
ever took power to oppress another group
throughout all of history said you know
what we want to oppress somebody they go
those people are oppressing up us so we
have to stop them and any and all means
which are necessary or therefore
justifiable because they're horrible
people yes and so when you look at this
story there's a really great lesson in
media framing here how did the
independent title this jane's revenge
group appears to threaten violence no no
a terrorist organization which has taken
credit for firebombing pro-life
organizations as well as charities that
are set up to help pregnant women care
for their children
is threatening
violence calling on more people to join
in yes
yo
that's crazy you know i do think that
this is a crazy thing to say but in
wartime terroristic violence does get
people on your side for instance like
the american revolutionaries were
terrorists according to king george
george washington was a terrorist and
henry knox
attacked an armory in i think it was
northern new york early early on um
killed a bunch of british guys stole a
bunch of british artillery took it down
to washington outside boston they sieged
boston they took boston and then the
french joined the americans so like if
if the americans were losing the battle
the french didn't join because of that
it wasn't but it was a result of victory
after victory and a belief that maybe
the americans could win if they if the
americans weren't
winning if they weren't doing this
terroristic destruction then the french
never would have helped them and they
would have been stomped out
but we're not in war that's a wartime
thing this is not a wartime thing but my
problem is people aren't upset about
this
that that that that is my my my central
issue right if you look at say for
example in new york state recently the
buffalo shooting right
everyone's mad about that no one's like
yay everyone's mad about that well well
that's what you think about this the
guns or the bad guys or the races or
whatever you think you're still not
happy about that
this is like whatevs and that's my point
there are enough people who aren't doing
anything about when they when they came
after the the judge when they came after
the judge i really thought thought
that this would be a big deal coming
after
a supreme court judge and now we do
nothing about that that is my problem is
is the apathy that's my biggest issue i
don't i don't think it's apathy and i
don't think people are whatever about
this i think they support it i think the
left is happy about it and i think
they're happy about what's going on in
front of the homes jen seki said we
certainly encourage more of this
when they were showing up illegally in
front of judge's home to try and sway
the court's opinion which is a federal
crime
then a guy who gets the address and
information from these same protesters
shows up to kill a sitting supreme court
justice that guy gets arrested and
charged okay that happened
the protesters come back that same day
and federal government does nothing
and my point is that the majority of the
country doesn't self-identify as left or
right like that they just think they're
average people and they lean left or
they lean right
that middle is what we is is the people
who should be angry people should say
look i'm not a hardcore leftist or
writer but i'm angry because this is
unacceptable regardless of my left or
right and that's what i'm saying people
aren't saying that i don't think there's
a middle you don't think so
no i think kind of in the middle here no
there's one guy see we got one no you're
not in the middle you know exactly what
we're talking about you know you know
exactly what's going on but when the
street violence kicked off in 2020 for
instance and they were bombing buildings
and destroying buildings i wanted trump
to send in the national guard and i was
like why day one national guard but then
i started to question myself am i an
authoritarian for wanting the national
guard to come in that is not the middle
but i mean you have to determine two
factions you go to the average person
and say what do you think about the fire
bombings at pregnancy centers and
they'll go the what yeah yep you go to
other people and they'll say i heard
about that that's crazy we got to stop
that those are the factions
so so the faction of those who aren't
paying attention you're saying i i
usually call it the uninitiated and the
discerning
the people who are inquisitive and
looking into the news trying to
understand what's happening in their
world versus the people who don't have
any don't want anything to do with it i
mean a lot of those
so i i uh
most people i think well i shouldn't say
most people but a lot of people
especially those who voted for joe biden
had no idea what was going on have no
idea what they're talking about at all
okay so you you go to them and you talk
about with any of this stuff and learn
to go what oh here's a great example
you know look i can respect bill maher
for calling out
entitled millennials in the woken all
that
but hearing him talk to crystal ball on
his show last friday was laughable she
brought up how everyone keeps ragging on
the mass printing of money but no one
said anything in 2020 when the fed
printed trillions of dollars to pump
into the stock market to stop it from
crashing right and bill maher goes what
are you talking about yes that oh bill
you do not have the position right now
to challenge your guests after what
happened with dennis prager crystal ball
was right right okay and she's a
progressive and she's right the federal
reserves are printing up money to buy
stocks and assets to bail out the stock
exchange the the markets because there
was a fear was going to tank and that
was bad yep
so bill maher that's his japanese style
stuff japanese do it all the time you
know if bill maher watched freedom tunes
he would have known that because he did
a video called corona
here's a guy
who has a show with a million viewers
once a week he does a what's a once a
week show he gets about a million of the
ratings and he doesn't know what
happened
two years ago with major massive fed
bailout spending that's like the biggest
story of the year but but but it's not
just that it's the hubris that's my
problem
i'm okay if he doesn't know but then why
is he aggressively pushing back cause
you go oh did that happen oh let me look
at that
hey can i get a producer on this yeah
get a producer to see if this happened
you know crystal that's a really great
point yes i wish i had known about that
yeah no he was wrong about covington
kids he didn't pay attention to that he
was wrong when dennis prager on his show
said they're putting menstrual tampons
in the men's room he goes no what are
you talking about this is exactly it
bill maher personifies now he may be
coming around right all of a sudden i
like his libertarian streak let's let's
reward the good behavior let's reward
the good behavior absolutely but this is
this is my point i think he is a
barometer for many of the what you what
you would probably assume is the middle
if you have people who are blindly
voting for the destruction of the
country and their values and their
economy and everything
i think bill maher represents exactly
why
they they watch him they listen to him
sure and he's years behind the curve in
what's going on in this country
so i don't view it as there are
political moderates and they're
extremists i don't view it as far left
far right and middle because well that
makes no sense they call i mean you're
libertarian they call you right wing or
far right or whatever they call me
everything bad they can think of exactly
yes whatever whatever they can call me
they call me right wing my pop my
politics are like centrist liberal
libertarian it doesn't matter you know i
can sit here across from sheamus and we
disagree on on the abortion issue
traditionally as this country did but
we're both far right there's no
distinction among
that group because they don't know what
we're talking about that's the media the
liberal well the liberal economic orders
media apparatus slandering people though
that's not a real
judgment call no no
but it does become real when they
brainwash people to believe it yeah
that's yes you have people who blindly
believe it and people who don't and
those are the factions there's no middle
there's no there's no person who's like
you know i do believe the narrative but
also not really it's like do you do you
know what's going on in this country or
don't you if someone said joe biden
tried to uh try tried to get a quid pro
quo from the president of ukraine
threatening to withhold us uh loan
guarantees in exchange for the firing of
prosecutor quid pro quo and people will
be like we had a guy in the show he goes
that never happened and i was like you
want me to pop the video and i pull up
the video and it's joe biden going like
so i tell him you want the billion
dollars you got to fire the prosecutor
well sob guy gets fired and i'm like did
you not even bother googling this story
you have people you're asking
i'm with you but there's two important
questions i think here number one
if that's true can you actually expect
the average american who's struggling to
survive as a general rule to spend that
much time understanding everything it's
it they become overwhelmed it's
information over it's it's just too much
information it's overloaded
so they're going to listen to whatever
their talking head tells them whether
it's rachel maddow or tucker carlson
whichever side they pick or if they're
smart temple whoever whoever's
whoever is there whoever is there
they're talking head of the day and
they're going to listen to them and
probably follow that person that's
that's
so that that's an element but i i see it
as on the right it's the exception on
the left it's the rule on the right you
have post liberals disaffected liberals
moderates libertarians conservatives why
because
the right is a group of people who are
like well i don't think tucker's right
all the time
i'll watch tucker i'll see what brian
stelter and rachel maddow are saying but
i want to know what the truth is you of
course have people who are like i just
turn on tucker and i tune everything out
sure and it's like okay well that's
you're probably better off than if
you're watching rachel maddow and then
you have people who are like whatever
anderson cooper tells me sure
but but
i think you find this you find this
right now with elon musk you found it
with joe rogan i would even say dave
rubin
many of these people were much more left
than right
but they stepped over a bound and some
was some barrier they stepped over and
the left said
not good enough how dare you and they
alienated the person and the person
believed well i can't be left so what
can i be and the right goes here we are
hey hey we love you joe we love you dave
we love you come on over
and they were more accepting it wasn't
that the i don't think it was the person
themselves was actually more
right-leaning but they were accepted by
the right because they felt shunned by
the left but there's no right the right
doesn't mean anything like what's a core
right-wing value right now
freedom of speech maybe if you if you
look at are you saying political are you
talking social when we're talking about
what left and right means colloquially
in cultural politics in in any kind of
politics yeah what is a shared
right-wing value i'd imagine it's free
speech
but hold on
the left historically was was in favor
of freezing 100 yeah joe rogan is not
conservative but they're calling him
right wing now and it's not that free
speech is a right-wing principle it's
that the left said okay we've now
decided if you're for free speech you
are no longer one of us well yes that
was and that's my point you're we're
we're on the same page here that's my
point is they were they were kicked out
versus they were pulled in the right
didn't pull them in they were thrown out
by the left
accepted by the right
that's my liberal yeah and i would agree
with you on that so we're in sort of a
strange position where what the left has
done culturally is they framed the
narrative such that this very
bizarre new ideology
which a very tiny sliver of the
population believes in is the dominant
view and if you're against that there's
only one other category for you which is
strange because i mean the united states
like developed western nations are
pretty much the only countries where
this ideology or some format exists and
even in those countries it's like maybe
three or four percent of the population
at most who believe it and yet it's been
framed such that there's that view and
then there's everyone else's view even
though almost no one in the world
actually believes in this and so it is a
problem you ask the question what do
conservatives actually believe i think
today because we have this framing and
everyone who's outside of that far
fringe on the left is conservative it
doesn't mean anything other than you're
not in this tiny group yes to me and i'm
conservative what i've understood that
to mean
is basically pro-family
you are in favor of tradition and many
aspects of culture
you you believe marriage is between a
man and a woman um you i guess it
depends on how far back you want to go
with respect to what was considered
acceptable in our culture but i think
that's at the heart of it when i hear
that there are people who are pro-choice
being called conservative it's not just
me as a purist saying i don't want those
people my movement it's just me
recognizing definitions have meanings
how can you be how can you be like in
favor of like homosexual behavior or
abortion and be conservative i don't
understand like that doesn't fit that's
not what the word means we had a
progressive on this show
and
sheamus mostly stated the conversation
and it was pro-abortion versus
pro-choice and the progressive view was
that i was far right for being
pro-choice
it's the weirdest yeah nonsense yeah
i've seen a lot of my friends in new
york city as they've gotten older who
were
democrats for years just
for a year parents were democrats
they're democrats and now they can't
find a home because they've been told
that well all republicans are evil so i
can't vote for republican i've been told
for 20 years the republicans are evil so
i can't vote for them right so but i
can't vote democrats i don't believe in
them anymore so they're checking out
now i'm trying to go to the libertarian
party obviously lp.org by the way lp.org
if you're in new york state lpny.org
by the way i'm trying to get them to go
libertarian but it's very hard because
they've been taught this this there's
two sides exactly there's only two sides
do everything we say
or not which is why you see so many
people are afraid to say the wrong thing
if you say the wrong thing they throw
you out of the tribe and you have to go
to the tribe
you but because in their minds there's
only two tribes the tribe i've been told
is evil for 20 years
and the trump i'm in now if i said the
wrong thing i have to go with the evil
people that i've been told for 20 years
or evil and it becomes a problem i think
comcast bought msnbc in 2013. right when
all this weird stuff started happening
and then they started telling everyone
these other people are enemies focused
stay inside of our grip and then so
they're starting to think those other
people are enemies and then everyone
else that's looking at these people that
are now being engaged in this cult
have a choice to make am i going to be
conscientious with these with these
people am i going to be
considerate and not take it personally
or they're calling me a villain am i
going to just strike back and and so a
lot you so you do see people going at it
but yes a lot of people aren't and those
people are still considered on the
outside of this media that's why they
hate the holiday of politics right i'm
out here campaigning right and i'm
meeting people and i find people who
very often do one of two things when i
talk to them they literally do not want
to talk like i can't deal with this
nothing to your point that totally
checked out right you would say tim i'm
checked out i don't want to talk to you
i can't handle this or the other one
they give me some type of test
to see if i fit in one side or the other
they'll ask me a question it's a test
okay are you gonna say this are going to
say that they'll say things we're
thinking about kids in school learning
by drag queens they'll ask that question
right and then if i answer the wrong way
then okay well i'm the opposite guy i'm
the bad guy whatever they want right
they do that all the time it's very
challenging because i'm trying to give
them an answer right i'm trying to show
them away and those are the people who i
begin to turn the people who are
interested
interested but actually feel like the
team i'm i was on sucks the team i'm on
now i'm not happy with
and that's the people who i get to turn
that group of people
the other side sucks decide i'm on now
not so good either let's talk about this
brewing case man i'm really excited for
this one we got the story from the daily
news it'll make you laugh
nyc mayor adams alarmed over pending
supreme court ruling that could ease
concealed weapons rules quote it keeps
me up at night oh poor baby a pending
u.s supreme court decision that would
allow more concealed weapons to be
carried on new york city streets has
been keeping mayor adams up at night
all of us should be extremely alarmed
about what the supreme court can do
when he says all of us is referring to
establishment authoritarians because yes
right not the people correct that's not
what he means yes yes because he's
worried about the wild wild west he says
right here's the problem i live in new
york city it is the wild wild west now
this this future dystopian thing you
think of is today
right so yes is that hilarious like
democrats always warn you about the
possibility of what they've already done
yes it's already there will be crime
everywhere it's like yes no we know that
that's a possibility because it's
happening in the places where you can
control yes check this out they say
under the state central law new yorkers
must show a specific need for why they
should be able to carry a concealed
firearm before they're permitted to do
so however in most states they just
reject your reason they go well you need
a reason that's not a good reason yes
which is ridiculous that law was
challenged by the new york state rifle
and pistol association bravo goodsterzin
and ladies which claimed it violated 2a
under the constitution supreme court
justices have suggested that they agree
that the law infringes on gun owner
rights and is expected to rule on the
case during the current term the
decision would also impact california
hawaii maryland new jersey and
massachusetts
oh you love to hear it yes it keeps me
up at night we have some of the most
stringent gun permitting laws i'm
extremely concerned about this my legal
team is talking to other cities
determine how we can come together to
prepare for this ruling here's what i'd
love
all right in dcv heller supreme court
basically said the right to keep and
bear arms extends to all states not just
from the federal government the idea
before was that the federal government
could not infringe upon your right to
keep and bear arms but states good dc
versus heller was like nah everyone can
have guns
and well i'm sorry that wasn't the case
uh that that was the case as it
permitted uh pertained to the federal
government in dc versus holler they were
like the federal government can't stop
you from having a handgun
it was mcdonald v chicago where two
years later they said
yes this includes all of the states as
well because it was the dc jurisdiction
now it was state now it was all the
state so it was nationwide you could
keep and bear arms all of a sudden we
see a wave across the country of shall
issue states meaning you apply for okay
you got to get
here's what i'm hoping for
i am hoping for the one in a billion uh
chance ruling that the supreme court
says
in fact any requirement of a permit is
in is an infringement upon your right to
keep and bear arms because let's be
honest it is
if you have to get permission from the
government and they can say no
your rights are being infringed
if it was to not infringe upon your
rights the government has no say
whatsoever i can keep and bear arms you
can't stop me what about a corporation i
know you are a 2a purist i know you are
yeah i'm actually not a 2a purist
well you're actually not a purist and
you need a loss sir we're going to
and here is my here's my and here is my
exception i think you could have a
regulation it is possible in theory not
in practice is how it works but in
theory you could have a regulation on
firearms that does not infringe how so
an example might be if you are going to
let's say this happens and a bunch of
people decide to buy firearms and we
find that smaller statute people don't
understand the power of uh you know
certain firearms and the backlash is is
hurting them and the state would say hey
if you're going to sell a firearm you
have to put a rating system on it that
would say big small little whatever
that's a that's a that's a regulation
but doesn't stop me from buying i can
buy what i want but if i choose to sell
it i've got to let someone know this is
rated one two or three when it comes to
recoil so i think that type of
regulation doesn't infringe but may be
good for the population as a whole to
understand well so so in in what way
do you see that actually something like
that being implemented
i'm saying i'm saying you said pure
purist i'm just pushing back on the
purity
i'm not saying i disagree with like a
rating system yeah i think when it comes
to things like commerce if you were to
say you you have to make sure that you
know you you maybe you give your caliber
in both you know imperial and metric or
something like i'm making these up
obviously but if you were to create a
regulation like that that doesn't
infringe it simply let's sumer know what
they're purchasing i think it does
infringe
i know your peers why i was teasing you
you're putting it that's exactly why yes
so the the challenge is
i think
the government using circuitous methods
to try and restrict things is a common
tactic and we shouldn't tolerate it but
again remember i said in theory not in
practice sure sure because in practice
the government will always do that you
know what they did with the stamp text
for marijuana yep they they said you
want to buy marijuana you got to buy
stamps then they stopped issuing stamps
yes yeah you know home i don't play that
so when you've got gun stores and
they're like we want to sell guns then
all of a sudden the government says it's
not an infringement upon the
individual's right to bear arms it's a
regulation for businesses what happens
when these businesses then go okay we'll
do the rating system who certifies the
rating system they go dhs okay how do we
get that done well dhs is shut down for
the next year
sorry you can't sell guns anymore so
it's an infringement infringement is
defined as an as an act so as to limit
or undermine something
if in any way there is a law passed
requiring you to do a thing they are
limiting your ability and if it's the
commerce of that is a private citizen's
right to keep and bear arms and
transacted us so let me push back then
it does say well regulated now when they
said regulated what they meant was
to make regular but right to do things
like to say what is regular but that has
nothing to do with the the with the uh
um
with the direction of the second
amendment the right of the people to
keep and bear arms yes but descriptive
statement to make regular would mean to
say things like um
to understand what caliber is right to
make a contract rule that i know when
i'm purchasing ammunition what is a
dozen but that has nothing to do with
the second amendment
says regulate writing the second
amendment and and why does it say that
to make it regular it would be like me
saying um libraries being important for
someone to read yeah people have a right
to access books
sure that doesn't mean the books can be
regulated or anything it's me making a
point about but what if it's said in a
well-regulated library
what if it's the benefits it doesn't say
that but what it says it will regulate
the militia being necessary to the
security of a free state yeah so what if
it said people need to have well regular
libraries let's say it said that
the people need to be able to have books
but the second amendment does not
require anything to be regulated i
already i didn't say requires
so what's what's the point of i'm i'm
saying that you could have a rule a a a
a you could have a law in theory again
i'm i'm purposely saying theory in
theory you could have a way of making
the practice of selling a firearm
regular that would not infringe on
someone purchasing it but regular has
nothing to do with what is prescribed in
the second amendment
it is describing their opinion on why
people should have guns and then it says
separately the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be in front
it also says a well-regulated militia
should not be infringed i think that
they're saying it doesn't say that a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed it sounds
like they're specifically saying that
the well-regulated you're right to
establishing a well-regulated militia
shall not be infringed
it's not saying that i mean the rest is
just the original second amendment
actually went on to argue that
um military or militia involvement has
no bearing on whether or not you can
keep or bear an arm that was actually
included in the original draft they
removed it because they were scared that
it would argue conscription isn't
allowed that people could reject
conscription so so let me then move to
the next important piece which you have
states like california and new york and
again i'm a new yorker so i get this
about ev every poll you take in new york
state about 60 give or take of new
yorkers actually want more gun control
too bad i'm saying they want it yeah so
with that in mind politicians are going
to act accordingly right they're going
to
regardless of constitution they're going
to act accordingly so they're going to
try their damness to stop everything
they possibly can so how do you move
forward in a state
like california new york that is going
to go out of its way to somebody go no
just no federal intervention and we do
it already like if you go to new york
city right now with a with a firearm
that you own it is on it is locked and
unloaded it is following every single
tsa guideline to the letter you will go
to rikers island that's right they will
take you and put you to rikers island
they wait for people to land knowing
that they have guns in the checked
baggage yep and they wait as soon as you
put a finger on the bag yup they come
and arrest you correct
that is new york city that is exactly
correct new jersey maryland very similar
yes so how do you because these cops are
scumbags so i know what you want and i
get what you want i'm actually not
against what you're saying
i'm
but i have a realistic issue here in my
state where most of my people in my
state think that more regulation is a
good idea i don't care what they think
and you don't have to you're not a
politician right if you're a politician
you've got to care because you're going
to vote for you they're going to put you
in charge and they're and they're the
ones who put the da's in charge so the
da's on the side who they're going to
prosecute who they're not right the da's
in new york city do this job because the
people in the city want them to that's
why they're doing it they're voting for
these das to do this and so people want
this so
we would need federal intervention into
new york to stop the infringement upon
people's rights and i view it as no no
different than if let's say new york
decided they were going to segregate
schools and the national guard or army
had to be called in to dec to uh uh to
desegregate that's probably a good idea
actually in new york because they do
segregate schools
so that's besides the point my view of
things is that um
the constitution is it's the founding
document the the supreme law of this
land you got a problem with it you can
amend it you need popular support to do
so and you're not going to get it you
can try and i i say that realistically
by all means i encourage everyone to try
to petition all of the states to have a
convention of states to make the changes
that they hope will happen there's a
reason why gun access is expanding it's
because most people actually want access
to guns when they say most people want
gun control it's because advocacy groups
are lying to you and i mean that
absolutely they say things like do you
think there should be background checks
for gun purchases and most people say
for sure yeah because there are then
they say people want universal
background checks then they say what
we're talking about is private sales you
didn't ask that of the person when you
took the poll right you look at you you
look at uh liberal gun owners of which
there are many yep you look at democrats
and it's like 50 some odd percent
own weapons you look at states like
vermont places like where bernie sanders
comes from and this shows you the
duplicitousness of these politicians
that bernie sanders comes from a state
that has actually one of the lowest ages
for owning a gun
that has some of the highest gun
ownership
where he campaigned in 2015 saying
weapons is a urban versus rural issue
yep today he says these gun control laws
don't go far enough because he is just a
lion it's like you described yes they
just want to get elected yes and they
won't just stand up and say this is what
is and why it is and if you want to
change it we can work to change it but
this is the way things are just because
60 of people in new york want to strip
the rights away from the american people
does not mean they get to yeah sadly and
this is the piece i'll bring up again
and people get mad when i say this the
only party that is even trying to do
what you're talking about libertarian
party that's right the only one
republicans are caving democrats in this
one i'll give them credit the the the
i'll give them credit recorders do at
least they're open about grabbing the
guns at least they're opening they're
saying we hate guns that's one thing
they're saying no the republicans say
they love guns and then still support
grabbing a gun this is true but you know
among democrats they go no one is trying
to ban your guns
take your gun
yes right they are trying to ban the
guns they're not trying to take them
what they do is they make you they make
you a criminal retroactively it's how
democrats are they're very good they did
my state atf did it with yes with the
with the 80 lowers 100 they're doing it
with ghost guns they're into 3d printed
guns yep so i was i was talking to one
of these um
uninitiated people who don't know
anything about guns but for some reason
want to regulate them they have
they have no idea what they're talking
about and they made it they posted a
meme where it said no one is trying to
ban your guns and then i said here's a
list of my guns that are banned in
maryland
so uh why the one i love to bring up is
the m1a which is a banned assault weapon
in maryland but the scar 20s is totally
fine even though they're a similar
caliber and one's more modern and
arguably better how does that make sense
how does it make sense that you can load
up a ksg25 with 41 mini slugs but you
can't have a six-shot semi-automatic
benelli because the laws make no sense
correct it's not about
it it is it's you know what you've
described it perfectly angry people who
who don't know what they're talking
about politicians who say yeah yeah
throw them whatever they want and the
system crumbles around us because
corrupt politicians offer stupid people
non-solutions that just go up the system
that feel good i'm gonna go one step
further here in new york i should say
here i'm not in new york right now but
in new york um we just had a a
democratic gubernatorial uh debate and
our governor just signed 10 laws she was
very happy she signed 10 laws to stop
gun violence
and one of the guys he was running is a
guy from brooklyn named jamani williams
and he said yeah but none of those laws
would do anything to stop gun violence
this was a democrat that said that
that's how bad it's getting your point's
exactly right they're just trying to say
i'm doing something so i'll sign this
law i'll sign that law i'll sign the
other law i'll put money into this i'll
start a program i'll do this thing but
they don't fix the problem the real
problem when it comes to guns if people
really care about the problem what
people hate about guns is the fact that
there are young people having mass
shootings that's really what most people
care about that whether that's gang
violence or whether that's buffalo and
places like that both of those issues
are the same thing
unhappy and broken young men
that's the issue what's killing our kids
is not the guns or the knives what's
killing our kids
are lack of purpose
lack of community and loneliness but
that's like that's what's killing and
that's hard to fight yeah that's hard to
fix it's way easier to sign 10 bills and
say i'm doing something like how do you
even how do you fix it because i mean
even the communist revolution and the
soviet union was a bunch of young broken
men yes it was and the mob was a bunch
of young broken men fascism is usually a
bunch of young broken men so that's who
the groups go for the age of that's the
ancient history of humanity young broken
men absolutely people are pointing out
new york city may want gun control but
new york state wants that's a myth all
the cities syracuse wants gun control
buffalo wants gun control ithaca wants
gun control rochester wants gun control
all it's urban versus rule yeah yeah
yeah so all the cities yeah i'm going to
say again i think that we're talking
about militia control this is i really
believe the second amendment implicitly
understands you have the right to
weapons and armor but it's in order to
you're right to have a well-regulated
militia i can start and control a
militia
you said how do you fix this
i brought this up literally four years
ago
four years ago about how i changed the
education system to where the kids get
out of school at 16 and then make
choices you go from k through 12 to
instead pre-k through through 10 and at
10th grade you you pass a test there's
your house diploma so make some choices
do you go to a two-year prep school do
you go to a two-year trade school do you
go to a two-year to get an associate's
degree do you go get a job do you start
a business go do something and have
purpose have kids go to every school
they want to go all the government does
new york state our constitution forces
us to pay for uh grades one through
twelve we have to pay it through our
constitution so you give them what i had
when i got a wrinkle which is the uh
basically i had a gi bill here's a bunch
of money go to college you have 10 years
to use it good luck we give all of our
kids at 16 20 000
five years go what will happen is a
bunch of schools will pop up that all
cost twenty thousand dollars every two
years because that's how the system
works and kids will go to schools they
want to go to kids will have more
purpose that their bullying goes away
fighting goes away all of a sudden kids
are doing things and taking action the
last two years of high school for most
kids last year for sure is garbage
useless why even have it it doesn't help
at all it's a weight colossal waste of
time which is why some of them don't
graduate and when they go to college it
takes them six years to grad she's not
ready for it the first year of college
is 13th grade you begin to fix that
number one you start fixing that it
changes everything make our kids make
decisions at 16 and not just be lost i
don't want a generation of lost men add
one more thing to that fix family court
family court is a disaster all it does
is crush and break families it takes
fathers out of the home it destroys
everything internally within families it
makes money everything and love nothing
i lost my father when i was 12 years old
i didn't have a father when i was a
teenager i would have taken a broke dad
over no dad any day of the week you have
to support the family by fixing family
court and then give kids more of a
chance the kids who are making all the
problems they're 16 17 18 19 20. vast
majority of those five those are lost
young men fix that you fix the problem i
want to i want to address second
amendment because uh there are people
asking about it ian
i say you were incorrect the
constitution of the united states of
america 1789
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed i ask you
ian
whose right shall not be infringed
according to that statement
the people who are the people
you and i and everyone here so the
rights of the people to keep and bear
arms should not be infringed what does
that have to do with the with the
descriptive statement well that it's one
sentence there's a comma if it was a
period after the word state does it say
the right of the regulated militia shall
to keep and bear arms will not be
different the subject of this sentence
sentence is a well-regulated militia and
at the end when they're describing
they're describing the subject of the
sentence there's no semicolon in there
there's there's there's three commas
yeah there's no semicolon so there's one
subject and that is the well-regulated
militia does it say the right to have a
regulated militia no they put that at
the end does it does what's the word
right that's how they wrote they wrote
like okay
the right of the people
is
the right of the people is a single
group of words it's part of a well a
well-regulated solution
that the right the constitution is
asserting in this that the right of the
people to keep and bear arms exists yes
they do not grant it it does exist it
shall not be in france the right of the
people to keep him bear arms is
necessary to the security of the free
state and which is why you shall not
infringe the right of a well-regulated
militia to the people
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state is an
explanation as to why the right of the
people to keep in bear arms will not be
infringed and this is the the standard
modern and every legal assessment of
what it means
well
i mean it's it's very poorly written by
today's standards we we really need to
update the constitution to make it but
the issue is people the existence of a
well-regulated militia does not have an
impact on the fact that the right of the
people to keep and bear arms that alone
between the commas is in existence yeah
none of these things these three things
should be infringed neither you're well
really regulated militia your free state
or your right to keep and bear arms so
then we can say this at very least a
well-regulated militia a free state and
the right to keep in bear arms all shall
not be in frame correct there you go at
the very least and let's see the actual
legal rulings on this so far is that a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to a security free state was
effectively an explanation
and as i mentioned i actually read
through the draft i believe they're
originally 17. there was actually an
amendment for the uh um the allocation
of congressional districts that are
crapping at 35 000 which would mean that
we'd have we'd have like 7 000 members
you've got no we'd have crazy congress
yes so they they ultimately said no to
that that was the original first
amendment i believe
the original second amendment they were
there like articles that were proposed
actually wanted to say that you had no
requirement to be in a militia to keep
and bear arms further explaining what
they meant by this they were scared that
by saying that people would then argue
you could not be conscripted so that you
could say you can't conscript me i have
a right to not be involved in the
military okay get rid of that
additionally if you look at the writings
of many of the founding fathers they
outright are explaining what these
things mean so what's in the
constitution is often simply
supplemented by like i wonder what they
meant when they said that well read it
they wrote books about it they wrote
tons of papers about it i got to go to
one step further which i brought up
earlier which is you have a huge chunk
of america
that would listen to everything you said
and go i don't care constitution's dumb
or whatever it's old or i don't care or
blah blah and you can say too bad but
those people vote our rights away every
year that's right so i have to convince
these people that you're right and it's
not i'm not going to convince them that
they're right because by i can't
convince them that the constitution's
correct by going back to the
constitution you have to convince them
that they're correct by other things and
here's some things that i do i'm one of
the weird people like not as good as the
guys like maj terrain others who do is
far better than i do but i talk about
the second amendment in cities
for me to go to the second amendment in
rural areas is literally preaching to
the choir they already got it like yeah
larry we got you already good already
done so i go into cities and talk about
it and i don't talk about the idea of
the constitution that's why the idea of
it being equalizer
right i discussed that issue of being an
equalizer if you look at what happens in
most cities and you lived in chicago
right you're from chicago right oh yeah
so you know most of the time the people
who are attacked non-gun non-gang
violence are people who they see as weak
someone who's older a mom with children
something like they'd see the person as
doesn't have a gun or is weak in some
way shape or form those people get
attacked but imagine if that mom or that
older person just in one city some place
drew down on a thug
pulled out a gun and put a bullet in him
they'll run away and they go wait a
minute maybe this is not so evil yeah
it's nucleus i say you want to take the
rights of gun gun owners away great what
about the woman who has a boyfriend or a
husband who wants to kill her well it's
an equalizer
that makes people rethink the second
amendment i'll tell you one better i
convinced a couple people
uh
they're posting about red flag laws
that's the big issue the the republicans
are working with democrats
my response is just
the goal of stop and frisk in new york
city was to get guns off the street the
police ended up targeting black and
brown kids and a lot of these kids were
innocent didn't do anything these kids
then find themselves getting falsely
charged there's a whole big scandal
about it and you even had one cop who
came out and said he was instructed by
the the leadership to target black kids
yep then michael bloomberg comes out and
says well that's who's committing the
crime just basically saying well sure
yes what do you think red flags are
going to do when you now have these same
people in charge saying this time go in
their home yes and i've had people go
you're right i didn't think about that
yes
yes well i go one step further with this
also which is they say but larry how
we're going to stop it i say in new york
city we already have something it's
called if you see something say
something there's no red flag law if you
see some bad guy going to blow something
up there's no requirement to report but
you know what we do we report
the only thing that's ever really
stopped any bad attack has been a
populist that called the cop and said
hey that guy shouldn't be there we
stopped that times square bomber we've
stopped these people with see something
say something let me requirement for a
red flag
let me tell you this
look up psychology today and any one of
these studies that show that the left
has a higher rate of mental illness
now you might it's a fact okay
so uh you might you might hear many
people say that that so i tweeted about
this marina lavatorov or whatever name
is she's avertalova yeah
navra
tolova there you go she was like what
kind of bs is this you made this up
google search left mental illness
there's just endless amounts of studies
now one argument from the left is that
well it's because people on the right
don't seek out mental treatment
therefore they never get diagnosed
whatever you want to say fine that's
fine by me the issue is
if you're a leftist and you're part of
say the socialist rifle association the
sra or whatever or uh vosh for instance
who's a socialist and very pro-gun yep
um you probably have a higher rate of
mental illness and let's just argue it's
because you're willing to get diagnosed
and you want better treatment right so
what do you think is going to happen
when the fascists rise up and there's
red flag laws and they say that guy is
depressed and it's marked down in his
files judge take his guns away now who's
got the guns it ain't the left
well here's the thing you were making
the point about stop and frisk earlier
the reality is the left 100 would have
supported stop and frisk if they
believed it would serve their political
interests right and so we're going to
see the exact same thing with red flag
laws obviously there's a very good
argument to be made as you have made it
that this is going to disproportionately
target black people inner cities but
guess what but guess what they don't
care as long as conservatives are also
targeted and if they know that a red
flag law is going to allow them to strip
you of your right to own a gun they
don't care how many black people are
also going to be stripped of their right
to own god i don't think so because they
only see them as political pods
what he's saying already in new york
state the same thing when it came out
literally it's used against people who
are black and brown in cities they add
that stuff on and i agree with it yes
it's not in my opinion going to be
targeting conservatives as much some
people have tried arguing to me saying
tim can the the the law enforcement
apparatus will be disproportionately
used against the right in some
circumstances perhaps
but but i don't see it in this instance
because you're talking about the
majority of conservatives who live in
rural areas right you you think that
you're gonna see a local sheriff show up
to jim bob's house who he might know
he's gonna be like i'll call him on the
phone or something tell him to come in i
don't know about that especially
considering you know these guys are
strapped in big cities
bloomberg people like him think about
kick the door in yeah do whatever you
want so
i'll put it this way i've thought about
the pros and the cons for me i believe
in freedom i think the left should have
guns i think the black panthers should
have guns i think the uh the the not
effing around coalition guys
very pro crt very poor trigger
discipline very poor trigger very
important
the guys who accidentally shoot yeah
okay guys you know you gotta we can't
have that but i'm just like you gotta
right keep and bear arms you want to
change it amen the constitution but i
think his point well he wasn't
disagreeing with you no but he was
saying i think no and i think we'd yeah
i mean i do still think it would be
disproportionately used against
conservatives for example where blue
areas where there is a conservative
neighbor who you know has a gun
everyone's going to report that guy or
in a suburb which is mixed and
people will will report the conservative
guy because he said something on social
media they disagree and what likely in
my opinion will end up happening is in
the wealthier suburbs where these people
are going to you know have lawyers or
whatever maybe that'll happen and then
you're going to see stop and frisk times
10 in inner cities yeah yeah i think
both will happen yeah i i think the on
top of that
as much as i believe in freedom what's
the end result of this a bunch of
right-wing people then say oh okay red
flags
they're going to start going it could be
4chan it could be any one of these
online forums they're going to start
going after every single leftist who's
trans or posts that they're
neurodivergent and they're going to say
they're posting scary things
and whether you have a gun or not
they're going to kick your door in and
it will be a legalized form of swatting
dude you'll have
people in the federal government hacking
people's accounts making it post stuff
that's false flag red flags and then
they'll be using that crap you just
can't do that you can't rap lyrics
you'll post rap lyrics you'll post punk
rock lyrics stuff's out of context you
can't use that as precedent and what
will happen is because red flag laws are
non-adversarial
the the call comes in the cops go to the
judge the judge they say here judge
here's what happened the judge says take
their guns away and then you're gonna
get some dude i'll tell you this it's
going to be in in a city and i don't
care about what the race it's going to
be in a poor neighborhood and the cops
are going to come kicking the door in or
coming to to take the person's weapons
away and you're going to have people who
are going to be like what's happening
what's going on i don't know what you're
saying i don't believe you also
i mean gangs could very easily put
someone up to red flagging someone in
their neighborhood they want to harm but
who they know has a firearm yeah like
this stuff could very easily be
yes i think the worst case scenario for
the left is just to imagine a bunch of
fascists weaponizing their mental
illness against them because they often
say they are and then the government
comes and takes all their weapons away
no more antifa armed no more forks
no more cutlery
no more pillowcases
come on what is this insanity no they
just want common sense pillowcase
control all right it's not happening not
this decade
i guess my point is when we look at so
much of what's happened over the past
couple years and i think particularly
the 2020 riots if the left views
the agenda of a particular group as
being anti-conservative they don't care
what happens to black people two billion
dollars worth of businesses were
destroyed in the summer of 2020. likely
more than that 30 plus people were
killed many of them in black
neighborhoods and guess what the left
defends it
they don't care it changes there's only
one way that changes is if you see the
black population
stop just always voting democratic
that's how it changes it is but the
hispanic population a whole lot faster
right you're seeing that that's a that's
a very fast change now asians
asians too if you see this swap though
if you see that uh uh the black
populations are going you know what
maybe i'm not voting democratic vote
libertarian or libertarian but anyway
but if they don't stop voting democratic
if they do that then the democrats will
have to stop taking that voting bloc for
granted and they'll have to actually
care but you're right right now they do
not care yeah because no matter what
they do
the black population still votes
democratic so i don't care if i bad with
them they still do it anyway yeah
exactly it'll shift there was you
earlier you mentioned the ny safe act
yep what a ridiculous gun control so
this one i believe this part of it was
actually struck down but you were
allowed to own a 10 round magazine but
if you put more than seven rounds into
it yep that was illegal correct
yeah so we we've got a bunch of studies
stupid i mean this is this is a this is
a very common story that came out a year
ago a year before that white liberals
are more likely to mental a mental
health condition we've got this from
zach goldberg as a doctor or other
healthcare provider ever told you that
you have a mental health condition you
can see that among white liberals it's
substantially higher double just about
double that of what people who are a
very conservative report conservatives
have the least the lowest level now what
i've heard some people argue like i
mentioned on the liberals
they argue that this is because liberals
are more likely to go to doctors
there it's less stigmatized among the
left and i'm like for the sake of the
red flag laws let's just say that's true
wow could you imagine fascists
exploiting the fact that you want health
care to take away your guns when you
want to defend yourself from the
fascists personally i don't believe
that's true because that would imply
that people who are very conservative
far right are more likely to go to the
doctor than conservatives which makes no
sense and it also makes no sense that
someone who is liberal and someone who
is very liberal would have different
degrees of stigma of a stigmatized view
of getting mental health therapy i think
what you're saying there's some evidence
of what you're saying already which is
you find already again for the safe act
you found people who are literally
they you have find veteran veteran
affects veterans more than anybody else
veterans are more likely to have a
firearm than non-veterans and they're
also more likely to have some form of
invisible injury whether that's ptsd
traumatic danger or something like that
that than non-veterans so you find that
a lot of veterans in their communities
will not go get help because they know
to your point in the second they have it
on their record
someone's taking their guns
and it's usually a family member who's
angry at them or sometimes a former
family member who's angry at them for an
ex a spouse a girlfriend who will now
take their gun away so yes it does
happen it's already happening in new
york state i was thinking of external
circumstances that can make people crazy
like new york city brake dust you know
there's brake dust in the atmosphere
from all these cars good goes it's so
small particularly small that it goes
through the avioli in your lungs and
right into your blood stream which is
way worse than like smog hype causes
hypertension which can lead to stress
which can cause to mental disorders
which can cause to a doctor visit so
like what just because you live near a
toxic chemical plant you can't have a
you and you're more likely to go
neurotic means you're going to be less
likely to have a weapon i don't like
that did you know that there was a
correlation
perhaps spurious uh between
leaded gasoline and crime rates and as
leaded gas lead started getting removed
from gas crime rates started to go down
uh some
i guess the speculation is as cars were
driving the lead was being you know
particularized or particulates were
going to the atmosphere people were
breathing it in it was poisoning them
and it was screwing with them it was
hurting their brains
so we got rid of that and then crime
went down i'm not saying it's a direct
causal you know a fact cause and effect
it could be a spurious correlation but
the fact is i think you make a good
point
there was also a study on happiness that
found that people who are in closer who
are closer to nature uh uh typically
have higher rates of happiness
so imagine you live in a big concrete
block that smells like sour milk and
break pads
you know we went to new york i went to
new york uh what was it like a month ago
two months ago man it stinks
it's crazy being out here in the middle
of nowhere and just all the different
smells and all the fresh air and the
trees we're surrounded by trees so it's
all just clean fresh air
and you go to the city and you're like
oh it's a unique wall but this is
and i think that actually ties into what
we're saying about mental health right
so left-wing people tend to be more
likely to live in cities what do you
think is better for your mental health
being packed into a small apartment
building like sardines and paying you
know two thousand dollars a month for
one bedroom and you're cramped and if
that's
what you live did i say 200 i'm sorry i
meant two thousand i know i know i meant
two thousand um no that's too low which
is probably like three thousand on
everything i'm sorry i'm sorry like
eight thousand dollars thank you there
we go
they let you sleep in the corner of the
elevator exactly um
but none of these things are good for
your mental health that's a good point
and it's not just what i think it's like
andrew huberman's uh neuroscientist has
done experiments that gazing into the
horizon for 15 minutes a day and having
that depth perception greatly enhances
neurogenesis and you know is going to
allow you to allow to not be stressful
to fix your brain
right oh it's funny to touch grass right
it's but it's true it works you go you
just go outside for a little while it
resets your brain i just love this when
people uh you know people post the meme
they'll like touch grass like you're too
online right and i'm just sitting there
like dude you are in a concrete cubicle
surrounded by concrete cubicles and i'm
looking out my window at a mountain and
trees in every direction and when i look
at when i look out the window you know i
see i see a groundhog we named him
winston and i see a bunch of rabbits
there's one rabbit that sits right in
front of the door he's not scared of us
at all nice and i'm like it's probably
not smart of that rabbit
what feed that dude but here's here's
the thing i'll tell you this
when every day you go out there's like a
fox running around and we're like he's
trying to go for the chickens we're
shaking our fists i saw a raccoon last
week we got wild turkeys
it's fun yeah they're hilarious when the
turkeys walked over to the chicken coop
and the chicken started losing their
minds it was hilarious
i lived in new york man there's no magic
there it is it is anger animosity nobody
knows each other nobody likes each other
there's people fighting all the time are
you in the city in new york city right
now i am based in i live in queens have
you been there for a long time aoc is my
congressperson good for you i accept
your condolences
for perspective do you get out of the
city frequently of course i'm i campaign
i go upstate new york all the time yeah
i i live in western new york
cause i'm
i i go all over the place i'm up a
little western york is probably our
strongest place and the libertarian
movement is strongest in western new
york in fact one of the counties in 2018
they got nine percent of the vote in a
county and there is a couple precincts
up in north country where i got like 25
to vote so north country is pretty
strong libertarian western new york very
strong libertarian um so yeah we have a
libertarian strongholds across the state
do you advise people to get out of the
city from time to time all the time yes
absolutely it's expensive i know for
your average you know maybe lower middle
class person to get up it's like 40 what
is it 40 bucks to take the train up the
grenadine backers the glory that new
york state actually is and and i wish
could be more you know our state's a
beautiful state there's everything you
can want in our state everything is from
madison square garden to niagara falls
to mountains and skiing to lakes to
fishing
to broadway to whatever is the thing you
like you can get it in new york state
the problem is our government is so
oppressive
that people can't stay here it actually
breaks up family is it because the state
itself is busy it's like they're
governing the state as if it was new
york city but then the rest of the
state's completely different correct
they the this is my entire issue right
the point i bring up constantly is a lot
of things that people are saying are
true but they're not going to happen in
new york state it's simply not going to
happen so my goal is several fold one is
to simply make it to where
we have more localization that is not a
perfect answer it's just a better answer
let brooklyn be brooklyn and let ithaca
be ithaca and let broome county be
broome county let the north korea be
north country
let them be their own most people who
are in new york state who are not
democrats who are republicans
independents uh libertarians
conservatives they want one thing to be
left alone that's what they really want
leave me alone they don't care about
brooklyn they don't care about manhattan
just leave me alone as they want so my
goal is to achieve just that i do that
that's realistic it can happen it can
work but i'll i'll bring up a more
important piece of everything we talked
about
none of it is going to be assisted never
going to work none's going to be fixed
if we don't have a third answer right
now everything becomes left versus
writer us versus them or whatever you
decide and the other person to your
point earlier is evil so i can do
whatever i want to hurt them or kill
them there's got to be a third entity i
believe is libertarian party i'm clearly
biased and i say that every time i am
but it might be maybe it's andrew yang's
forward bar which is why i made a
connection with him maybe it's that i
don't care but i'm i think it's mine i
think it's my party but it's got to be a
movement yes that that allows other
people to talk to each other without
pointing a finger that allows people to
go you know what you do you i do me
we're good and right now it doesn't
exist so that's libertarians are on the
right culturally and why do you say that
i mean it's just it's in the culture war
in the context if you go to a leftist
and say you're a libertarian they will
say you're right-wing
i think that's i think that's often true
because many people who are re
republicans who
call themselves a battarians when
they're not but they're not they're not
libertarians though correct they're
not i mean i mean liberals and and the
establishment left and modern leftists
do not believe in libertarianism and i'm
talking about that in the philosophical
not the not the big libertarian party
i'm not sure where you're going you are
you're telling me that
are you telling me that culturally
people think we are on the right or are
you saying that libertarians are on the
right in the culture war the libertarian
party is
no different than conservatives
okay we are
as a party we are far more left-leaning
socially than republicans are sure far
more and the culture wars heavily about
social issues right so how can you say
we're right-leaning
when we
join the left in most of these things
like what what things did you join the
left-hand uh cannabis as an example
right drug war the right is all about
support the drug war cannabis is evil
the left is like cannabis is good and
libertarians are further than left then
yeah most democrats are like let's just
regulate and tax cannabis libertarians
are like let it all go
so it's definitely changing the
republican party though we're left when
it comes to
gay rights the the gender sexual
minority community we're far left on
that
further than that trump was
gay marriage yes but you said
conservatives donald trump is right
right sometimes sometimes
the republican party then so
the republican party is viewed as as
right-wing libertarians are viewed right
alongside it viewed as i'm agreeing with
that but in reality i'm not sure that
the issue is the point i'm making is
when i go and so first of all when
people try to accurately describe me and
i'm not talking what the media says they
say like libertarian center or like
libertarian liberal center stunningly
attractive stuff
but
that
that's a fair assessment when i go and
talk to
progressives and leftists they say
conservative far right 100 percent we
had vosh on the show and he called me
far right yep and so you mentioned a
space where you can bring people
together and it's like yeah but look
when we bring on these progressives they
outright tell us they disagree with what
you said they yes they should have a say
in other people's lives period i agree
so when you say most people want to be
left alone you're not talking about
bringing both sides together you're
talking about trying to appeal to to the
common person who wants to be left alone
yes that's that's what i'm saying yes
but you did you did like three different
things in there the first thing is if
you're saying am i viewed by most as
right-wing that's true most people say
that most of the time my biggest issue i
have in in when i'm running for office
is the when the rights angry at me it
comes at me right the right will say
you're wrong because this and i love
that because i'm a master of judo so i
will take them and i will take their
attack and put them down i i can turn
people from the right fast and from the
left the left will simply ignore me they
will just ignore me not talk to me
dismiss me i need to draw which is why i
like guys like rosh because voshwa is
attack yeah right and i want people i
like old debate bros i like destiny i
like bosh i like dylan burns because all
those guys are left but they will attack
me and i can have a conversation with
them so much of the left will not even
talk to me and i beg i reach out and beg
them to talk to me and they just won't
do it you're correct but that's because
they believe
that i am right-wing even though i'm not
that's not neces it's not so much about
the fact that you're right-wing it's
that they have no argument
the people who have arguments will argue
the people who don't won't and typically
among the left don't have arguments
well but that doesn't that doesn't
answer what i was talking about right i
don't think that we are are rightlying
it at all i think we need writing
certain things but i don't think
libertarians actually are right and i
think the the culture believes we are
well when they talk to us they go oh and
why i said this because when i get
people from the left
to talk to me
they often stay
but i'm referring to they stay the
culture the cultural uh scale not the
the economic skill so right and left
mean very very very you have to define
what left and right means i'm using in
the context of if you were to walk into
a room full of people who listen to
podcasts left and right has a meaning
you are right wing
if you were to talk to someone about
social policy and economic policy you're
probably center or something that effect
but that's not relevant when you're
trying to get people into a room when
you have big media funding the
colloquial definitions yeah than writing
valid means
so that's what i mean to say you made
the point that you want to create a
space where you can bring everyone
together and it's like oh i love that
idea but like you said the left will not
have those conversations the only people
we get two kinds of people that want to
come on this show that are on the left
and i should say mostly grifters
who are trying to manipulate us and
exploit us to then turn around to their
fan base hoot and holler and then and
then screw us over right either not come
on the show cancel the last minute which
you've had many of or just start
tweeting bs accusing me of things that
never happened so they'll you know we'll
get them on the show and they'll say oh
tim did this and oh now oh geez and then
try and get press out of it we then have
people who have like no following they
have no body of work they're not very
active in politics they're just small
accounts that have maybe a couple
thousand followers right and they have
no strong arguments they want to come on
the show and you know what happens when
we invite these people on the show they
sit there dumbfounded confused having no
idea what to say
i've had that same issue right as i've
tried to reach out to the left more and
more i brought people obviously have a
smaller show but when i bring with my
small show i sometimes have an issue
where my my people get mad at me because
i have to use kid gloves
because if i don't use kid gloves i make
the guests look really bad good do it
and i don't want to make the guests look
really because i'm trying to be i'm
trying to i want the left to come on my
show and if i beat them up too badly
then nobody comes back anymore so i have
a similar issue where sometimes i bring
someone on who is just they're so
accustomed to talking within their own
bubble
that everybody right is wrong that when
they call my show they're unprepared for
anything i've got to use kid gloves or
make them look terrible this is why you
get people like jordan klepper who go
down to rallies to find the oldest and
most ignorant among the trump supporters
to make that the focal point because
when i think it was vish burra actually
met him on the show when he actually
talked to jordan clapper clapper is like
uh-oh it reminds me of during occupy
wall street when um
i forgot the dude's name he was uh
jessie lagreca shout out to jesse
lagreca he was being interviewed by
griff jenkins of fox news and he went on
this tirade about how fox was not going
to actually share what their real
opinions were and the video was secret
was being recorded by somebody else fox
never aired the interview and then the
left got a hold of it published it and
they were like this
fox won't tell you what the occupy wall
street people are actually concerned
about the funny thing is the things we
talk about the federal reserve freedom
liberty was exactly what was being
espoused by some of these people that
occupy wall street although
unfortunately eventually i got taken
over by social justice leftists and then
absolutely but but that it feels very
much the same way today where
you you take a look at uh
you know i'm surprised bill maher has
ben shapiro on but even when he does he
like falls back even though ben shapiro
is right but you take a look at msnbc or
cnn they don't have on anyone who can
actually stand up to the debate the
january 6th committee will not have
anybody who can actually no wait hold on
it's it's bipartisan they have liz
cheney that's right oh that's true that
makes it all right i'm sorry yes
everything you've just said tim is
completely wrong because liz cheney is
there so now yes except that accept your
shame yeah exactly
i do believe there's a culture war going
on 150 years probably since the since
the opium war in china the british
colonies tried to force opium into the
country the chinese play the long game
and now they're using i don't know who
it is that's doing it but somebody is
using this media junction of like
comcast and verizon and google and
google is now alphabet i don't know how
involved you guys are at alphabet with
this stuff but like to spread a message
which just to crush these people into
this cult mindset and everything else is
right it's on the right if it's
libertarian it's on the right if it's
something else it's on the right if you
don't know what it is and it's it's on
the right don't listen to it that's a
part of that too i agree there's a part
of the idea of the censorship is
self-censorship right i won't i won't
watch this show i won't look at this
thing i won't read this thing because
it's on the right or whatever the case
maybe there is a lot of self-sensitivity
and the stuff that they're missing is
the talk about the federal reserve
international banking
fiat currency but i think some of that's
changing right i do think there's a
there is it's not as fast as i want it
to be but i do feel like there are
enough people who are saying
something's wrong like i don't get it
but i just know something's wrong to
your point and they're not educated
themselves enough but they feel like
just this isn't right and they're
looking for something which is why i
think so many of the podcasts are
exploding alternative media is exploding
because they're like who's that guy you
were talking about i want to watch that
guy where where two years ago like i'm
not watching timmy some crazy guy and
now they're like who's that guy let me
go check his show out i think we're
getting more of that oh yeah i do think
it's happening but then after they watch
for two years they go oh he's that crazy
guy he's not watching that crazy guy
yeah when i thought i saw blackrock
tweening on trending on twitter that i
mean that's a breakthrough yeah it's the
psychic the psyche mind yeah well you
made this point it sort of touches on
something i was saying earlier about
this very small fraction deciding that
there the totality of the left like
everything else is right wing this is
something you can even find with like a
political compass test when you take one
of these surveys yes you can tell who
wrote it you can tell the ideology of
the person putting the questions into it
and so that's very much the case with
many of the culture war issues you can
tell who's deciding what we're going to
end up talking about and that they're on
the left almost always with a few
exceptions now that we're talking about
grooming etc you can tell well
conservatives are actually starting to
have their voice heard but for the most
part everything we've talked about has
been what the left wanted us to talk
about you'll take a political compass
test and the question will be something
like do you believe women should have
the right to choose whether or not to be
a mother yes yeah right and then you're
like okay i know who wrote that right
it'll be like do you think an employer
should be able to beat any of their
employees to death with a hammer for no
reason and you're like no they're like
you're a communist you're on our side
like you're with us
you believe in workers rights you said
it right there yes i love um
have you watched squid games yeah
the funniest thing to me is that these
people desperately want to claim it is a
critique of capitalism sure and
apparently the the guy who wrote it like
the story saying like he was writing a
critique of capitalism and netflix
didn't want to buy and took him like
seven years or whatever and my at my
response was if that guy
he it really was writing a critique of
capitalism he's a perfect example of a
leftist who has no idea what capitalism
is also i just want to say the idea that
any media company wouldn't want to buy
a film or television show which was a
critique of capitalism that's like the
most boring market safe thing you can
write everyone makes critiques of
capitalism that's not it the point was
that he offered up the show they didn't
want and then when they finally bought
it it was successful uh it wasn't that
he was like i want to critique
capitalism okay okay i understand i
understand here's a funny thing squid
games ah i know it's an old show by now
but i just love this idea here's a show
where in like one of the first games
everyone has to wear the same clothes no
one is allowed to leave and everyone
starts at the equal point at the same
line you then have to try and make it
across this field where you're
effectively cutthroat and pushing people
and trying to beat everyone else and
those who don't make it die
and i'm like what about that is
capitalism in cat if it was capitalism
everyone be wearing different clothes
you can leave at any time and some
people would start halfway across the
finish line or halfway towards the
finish line communism is where everyone
is forced to start at the same point
with the same clothes and you can't
leave and if you try you get killed well
i don't think you realize this tim but
um
any term which is associated with the
right just means bad thing bad thing
yeah yeah so whenever any any bad thing
happens on television that was like
capitalism or conservatism or something
i just i i thought it was funny where
they're like this is clearly capitalism
and i'm like if you look at historic
it's because they believe in ideological
communism
and so it's the they'll just take
whatever they can and say it's it's it's
capitalism because it's bad and then i'm
just like bro in the capitalist system
you can choose to just be homeless and
just leave or not play the game right
game if you tried to leave they killed
you right that's communism when you try
to escape a communist country what
happens right they throw you in the
gulag or they kill you what sounds not
communist is how they have to challenge
fight each other in the free-for-all
part because in a communist system they
would be working together and it doesn't
matter it's not just there
during the soviet union
during the soviet union that's true but
that's right that's why i'm saying
actual communism yeah capitalism you can
leave you can you're like my neighbors
screwing with me i can go to the courts
and petition in communism i had a friend
who is uh in ukraine and when i went to
her apartment she explained to me how
there are two apartments next to each
other and the neighbors were having a
feud so one one person called the the
communist party and said my neighbor is
badmouthing the party and the next day
their apartment was empty jeez send them
to the gulag that that that that was the
reality of communism people were
cutthroat if you wanted to survive you
needed to do whatever it took to get
food and survive i keep thinking about
communism and how it creeps in and it's
not a political party but it's just this
idea that all of us are going to control
everything together we're all in this
together you guys does sound good
there's no doubt the rhetoric of
communism is amazing rhetoric and if you
go back to 20 say
2016-ish the the left rhetoric was way
better than the right rhetoric was it
was all about we're all going to be
together and we're going to be it's all
going to be there's going to be rainbows
every day it's going to be amazing and
we're all going to get unicorns it's
going to be great the rhetoric is
awesome but when you see it in play it
doesn't work and my example is my state
my state is the example literally in new
york state a republican has not won a
statewide election in 20 years
the state has been run by democrats for
20 years we've been putting more and
more rules and regulations and laws and
all those things and it has not gotten
better by anybody's recollection that we
have been listed by cato multiple years
as the least free state in the union
take that california number one in terms
of yes we are number one in terms of not
good in terms of democrat rule illinois
would like to have a word with you oh is
it it's been longer than that i think
it's like 80 years or a hundred years
was it has not won
not state so there's no statewide at all
no
illinois has no settlements i should say
no i don't say chicago no i'm sorry oh
yeah that's that's not fair because new
york city is probably new york city well
new york city also remember a new yorker
a new york city republican
is like a oklahoma democrat that makes
any sense
bloomberg was our republican mayor so
yeah that's not giuliani is republican
he was yes but if you look at new york
state state meaning senator attorney
general lieutenant governor governor
congress
congress yes best federal yes but i'm
saying a statewide election new york
state has not had okay
is it because they control the media
marketing message in the state like they
get to pick where the billboards go
because outside of the cities in new
york there's basically been no recovery
since 2008 there's no recovery so the
only place to find a job is in cities so
people flock to cities and that's the
reason why the the country after 2008
made a very fast shift towards the left
that is changing now and that's probably
one of the better things for kovid to be
forward um the the coveted lockdowns had
so many horrible effects but one of the
effects it had is many of the cities to
begin to empty and as people rush to
cities
they become more left we live on topics
as you said who live on top of each
other we we don't have the same religion
background we don't have the same
language culture we cry for a referee
the referee is almost always government
so we cry for more government we cry for
referees people tend to become more left
as they live and grow and work in cities
when they go back now which is happening
now i think you'll find many people as
they go back into the rural areas and
into the suburban areas there's an
opportunity for them to be a renaissance
in the suburban areas and that people
become more what i would think as more
neutral or more having left and right
and not being hardcore left or hardcore
right i would hope that would happen did
you see that indoor farm in uh jersey
maybe in jersey city aerofarms is the
company it's the largest indoor farm in
the world or it once
right near the city and i wonder if
indoor farming is something that they
could do in new york because i mean in
the winter
you lose the crop essentially we have a
bunch of empty buildings in new york
city so it's not a bad idea
we have tons of empty buildings in here
today now i mean them people are not
going back at all then new york city
is gonna in my view will drop below
eight million and never come back past
eight million again because there's
simply the glory that was new york city
is a 16 million metro person areas in
the metro area with 60 million people so
if you wanted talent if you wanted
customers if you wanted anything and
banking finance was in new york city you
would go to new york city to get your
stuff but two things have happened with
remote everything you don't have to be
in new york city now to get the talent
you want and
in the bet in the back of the day
tech followed finance
those days are over now finance follows
tech so wherever tech goes finance
follows them new york city is no longer
no longer has to be that center for
finance anymore austin can be it dallas
can be it uh san francisco can be it so
new york city's gonna bring it all to
west virginia well you what you gotta do
is you have to make new york city what
it should be which is a cultural center
that it still has and still will be in
these the culture is what will save
you don't think it has it i don't even
know yeah i don't know that i would
agree with that
that's all been decentralized too with
social media i mean people can make
anything from anywhere yes however when
it comes to culture i mean things like
if you if you want to be a a classic
pianist if you want to you know work on
broadway if you want to be you know a
ballerina if you want to be that kind of
thing still right now new york has that
now you're right if they don't take
advantage of it it will be decentralized
and they'll lose it but they have to
focus on that how to keep it i i i i
somewhat disagree they do have it of
course yes but the scale matters so
we had uh
i mean we had 40 000 concurrents at peak
on this show that's two madison square
gardens yup
so imagine if we actually were like new
york's the place to be because i want to
do a big show to 20 000 people man and
then we're going to be in madison square
garden it's like or you can just get a
live stream and get twice the audience
size yeah but that's the cultural issue
again this is you want to physically be
there's a reason why people want to go
to broadway sure sure but my point is
just just because you want to work for a
print newspaper doesn't mean you're
going to have influence beyond someone
who works for an archaic medium so
if you what do you mean by that you want
to you you personally want to be in new
york well no that's fantastic i want to
go and watch a broadway show right right
i want to go and watch
live ballet and less people do that
correct than consume media online
absolutely true which is which is my
point that you are more likely to
develop culture outside of new york than
inside of it it's the internet i mean i
left new york for this reason it was
expensive and was not conducive to
building any kind of media brand i left
it i went to south jersey couldn't do it
in south jersey
we're we're in the tri-state of western
maryland west virginia and we're moving
we're building a headquarters right now
in west virginia in the middle of
nowhere
and you know you know what it was i was
thinking you know the challenges we got
to get guests and if we got to the
middle of nowhere how do we get guests
and then i looked at the time from jfk
to uh to a brooklyn studio and it's two
hours an hour and a half and then i
looked at the time from dca or iad dc
airports or even baltimore to where we
are now it's actually less time yep i'm
agreeing with you but yeah but the issue
is when it comes to cultural issues like
that there is an infrastructure that has
to be built
if you want to have an art
infrastructure that
right now exists in new york city but
what does that mean it means if you say
for example you want to be a uh you want
to watch the ballet there has to be a a
customer base
you can but you want to watch it live
and lots of people do literally
thousands of people do millions of
people come to new york city because
they want to watch stuff live sure it's
a special issue now my point is if new
york city doesn't do a better job of
cultivating that your opponent is
correct some other place or other
players will no no i'm saying that
that's already done
the so the the idea look
i was uh we got we got times square
billboards and uh i don't want to say
too much but wow is it bad in new york
yes there's no one cares anymore nobody
wants to be there shows do not do well i
know it's over there it's a problem and
and
one of the billboards in times square
was off
i said how is it off
just it's off there's nothing there no
one wanted this space
i won't say too much but they turned it
back on
and now we're thinking about it because
we wanted to do some uh we did it to
make a statement like we're here but we
know it's because the the cultural
establishment is in retreat it's in
decay and that's our opportunity to
assert ourselves
but now i'm i'm looking at it i'm like
what's the what's the positive impact
it's it's negligible sure some people
want to go to new york to watch it watch
a ballerina they do i assure you if you
right now want to be a famous ballerina
you will be wasting your time by going
to new york you are better off making a
youtube channel learning on your own
hiring a private tutor and then doing
youtube videos you go to new york to do
it you'll have a quarter of the audience
size and you will be archaic you do it
on youtube you save money you will get
more viewership and you'll be more
relevant and then they will fly probably
the best you could do is be in new york
doing it on the ground and with a
youtube channel because people like
seeing a real life ballerina doing it at
home and then once you're famous having
them pay to bring you to this place yeah
so i think that when you're whether
you're looking at new york chicago los
angeles any of these giant cities i see
them the way
i see well uh get out of here all right
um
and your pizza is not good either no i'm
kidding uh but the way to get out i'm
giving it
a hard time the way i look at these
large cities is they're like wealthy
families and what happens to a wealthy
family generally speaking is within a
handful of generations less than a
handful the wealth is gone because the
younger generation that inherited the
wealth doesn't know as much about
building wealth as the person who
amassed it in the first place and so you
see a lot of these cities and for a long
time they did have advantage just based
on the technological infrastructure that
was accessible to this country based on
their location uh geographically subways
but now as you've mentioned there are
reasons that people don't need to be in
these states so you said capital follows
uh innovation and technology rather than
it being the reverse so what do wealthy
people do and what have they done
historically well they've patronized art
which promoted things that they loved
correct and so
because new york was so wealthy we had
the arts being patronized there yep and
i believe you're just going to see less
of that new york is going to be less of
a cultural center because the people
earning wealth are going to be in other
areas and they'll want to fund it there
yeah well something else happened the
the government has much more the
government has much more power now than
ever right and what you're finding is
people are moving to be outside of dc
yeah well because they want to be close
to centers of power right yeah which
and every other country that does not
have a decentralized or if you look at
every other country right you want to
capture their capital because their
capital is their political capital it's
their cultural capital it's their
financial capital america's been blessed
we have a different capital new york has
always been our financial capital you
know la was our cultural capital when it
came to movies and stuff like that dc
was up was our was our capital when it
came to politics now it's all shipping
towards the dc area right and the
structure of texas too but because
politics is so important in creating
monopolies and things like that you're
seeing people wanting to be close to
power you know is it changing in new
york and l.a shrinking that doesn't
bother me but dc growing horrifying i
agree with you i agree with you
completely i think it's it's a it's a
challenge that we see but i'll go back
again and i know my broken record but i
don't care i'll do it the answer is stop
voting left and right yeah you just said
the answer is stop voting left and right
what does that mean
um more libertarian yes
or yes i mean look if you lean left
maybe you vote for round but vote
libertarian what i'm saying is vote
third party because if you don't vote
third party there is no reason
for any democrat or any republican to
solve a problem right now in america
there are democrats to the party the bad
ideas and republicans the party have no
ideas they're not fixing anything and
there's no need to fix it they won't
because we just keep one up the right
and we go well the most important
election i got to make sure that you
know biden doesn't win again great so
trump wins four years later what do we
get aoc
and then four years later what do we get
ted cruz and then four years what do we
get
omar
remember something please never forget
this for you guys who are all worried
about i gotta make sure this is the
right election remember something bush
got us obama
obama got us trump trump got us biden
nobody's winning here i don't care
whether you lean left to lean right
nobody's winning nothing's changing if
you get a powerful third party that can
begin to move the other parties and
that's doing something something might
get changed why would the libertarian
party not trigger a similar backlash in
the opposite direction
what's the opposite direction like i
would suppose more government authority
who voted for trump likes trump they got
everything they wanted from him they got
an end to the tpp they got biden
that's they wanted that they got biden
no no they voted people who people who
voted for biden didn't want biden
okay well they want to trump a drink
people who voted for trump were happy
with trump and that's why but they're
not happy
13 more 13 million more people voted for
trump in 2020 but there's not matter if
you get biden the problem so listen if
you're ba if you're mad about bush and
you're mad about obama yeah but then
you're happy about trump and then you're
not about biden you're gonna vote for
trump again because trump is what you
want great so you get trump for four
years then you get who next you get
kamala harris i mean you're you're just
you're delaying your pain for four years
i'm saying begin to fix the system i'm
saying let's say people voted for trump
because he was what they wanted people
they weren't voting against i got you
people who loved obama
think obama was great people who love
trump think trump is wonderful so if you
love obama or you love trump we need to
keep waiting for another obama trump to
come what happens when there's no trump
or obama up top what happens when the
system's so broke and there will be no
more trust i don't know
anything outside of if people want to
vote for trump because trump gave him
what they wanted why wouldn't they vote
for him because they're going to lose it
in four years that's why but why they're
going to vote for they vote for a
libertarian they're going to lose it in
four years no they're not because when
libertarians begin when any third party
begins to make actual impact things will
begin to change ross perot showed us
that
ross perot was as he tried to do good i
was a ross supporter back in the 90s
when ross tried to do good he did try to
do good he i think he thought he was
doing the right thing he wound up
closing the door behind all of us
because once the left and right saw that
ross pearl could actually make any
impact they then created systems to make
sure no third parties can ever do
anything ever again whoa and then trump
won through the system and he went
through the system because he crushed
the tpp which both republicans and
democrats wanted which was a shock to a
lot of people well and i want to mention
too you're talking about one candidate
getting another candidate i think
bringing up ross pro is a little ironic
i like him but there's a good argument
to be made that he got us clinton
otherwise they're like
bush senior yes but but let's say he did
let's nader got us bush but let's say
that that he was able to actually win
the thing of argument perrault was able
to actually make a change where he
actually won that would have shaken
everything up
and i'd rather have that
if you look at what's happening now
it's not good it's a uniparty at least
that's how well and here's my problem so
to some extent i agree with you so i'm
i'm conservative i think the republican
party they're mostly empty suits but
then there are republicans who come
along who i really do agree with and
think would do good things and in that
case i can't vote for libertarians i
used to be libertarian but then but here
but then here's my problem with that is
for people who are not completely
ideologically libertarian introducing
the libertarian party is just giving
them the lesser of three evils rather
than the lesser of two evils and it's
like if i'm gonna vote for the lesser
evil i'm gonna vote for the people who
are more likely to win to mitigate the
destruction that the other side's trying
to bring against me and here's what i
would buy with that if you want to do
that it's great but then find the guys
that you like or the gals that you like
that are running september the problem
is we get dismissed right shane hazel's
running right now in georgia ricky
harrington junior is running right now
in in arkansas believe it or not we
actually have a presidential candidate
mike termatt that's t-e-r-m-a-a-t for
those of you online um he's actually
running for president right now right
he's already started he's starting now
but they'll be dismissed what i'm asking
anyone to do is to simply say you know
what if you're a third party particular
libertarian i'm biased but look at but
look at a third party with the same way
you'd look at a left or right and if you
find the guy or guy you like vote for
them because if they begin to do well
they will affect others but once you
start saying if you're telling me i like
this republican please vote for that
republican if you tell me uh this
republican sucks but he's not a democrat
that's the wrong reason in my view i
come to write for i'll vote i completely
agree but i think is being overlooked is
that donald trump was not a traditional
republican he was not part of the unit
party he brought in a wave of
new voters people who never voted before
and so he just basically stormed into
the republican party forced the neocons
to join the democrats people like bill
crystal people like the lincoln project
and people voted for him because he gave
them exactly what they wanted and it was
so good for many of them that he went
from i think 62 million votes in 2016 to
74 in 2020 still the people who voted
for biden didn't want biden they just
hated trump correct so that i i don't i
don't see you i i understand the point
about
it it's bad that it's just left no but
here's my point but if someone like
trump
was nowhere near a traditional
republican and no way a bunch of changes
unless changes stand so imagine if he
had run as a third party and could
actually if there was a system involved
where he could act against third party
that's another thing that's why he runs
republican but he runs republican
they'll also have something else a very
popular person who was also wealthy
how are you going to keep finding that
and do we want that to be the thing that
we're always looking for but that's not
a good idea we have to break a system
but that makes no sense tell me why
they like trump for his attitude he
happened to have been wealthy rodney
santos is now rivaling trump and he's
not like trump in many ways he's like
trump in certain policy ways but he's
got military experience he's younger and
he's nowhere near as wealthy but he
could actually win a presidential
election so the issue is lots of people
can win a presidential election the
point i'm making is that
you've got rhonda sanders and donald
trump running and the people are excited
for them and enthusiastic about them
they're getting what they want just
saying well if you vote for you're gonna
get biden it's like sure you've got bad
ignorant people in this country who vote
against things you like you'll never
change that but if you've got people you
do like who are running and you're like
this is fantastic vote for it
let me give you a good example since i
know you like what trump did all right
some of it
trump in the first couple years
struggled a bit most people would agree
with that he struggled to get uh on
track the system was aggressive
yeah well the system was against him
right the system was against him right
so he couldn't get what he wanted if you
look instead i'd say someone like obama
also struggled the first year but guys
like clinton and bush who were former
governors didn't struggle as much their
first year they kind of knew how to deal
with the system so both of them were
able to get more stuff done in the first
year or two than than obama and and and
um and trump because theoretically they
were more outsiders than those first two
so wouldn't it be benefit a system where
you could have a third party that could
move both sides to your point earlier
the democratic party is supposed to be
about civil liberties they're clearly
not but they're supposed to be
libertarians why do you say that you
don't think they're about civil
liberties no absolutely not that's what
i said they're supposed to be them no
they say they're not supposed to be
there yes they are when oh my god yes
absolutely if you go back to the 60s and
70s
democrats were the ones about free
speech
well yeah the left 100 percent
absolutely they're supposed to be about
they're not but
we say it's supposed to be it's like a
very short-lived and new thing for
democrats relative to the history of
this country i mean democrats
historically were the opposing civil
rights for for people yes and even to
this day yes but even today yeah they're
pro-segregation they're anti-free speech
but if you ask it's like a small blip
but if you ask a democrat
they always talk about democracy and
freedom so their rhetoric is that
but they're not that the republicans are
supposed to be about small business less
taxes they're really not about that
either there's more debt so they're
about more debt than anything else
they're not that either but if you had a
third party to shift them and move them
towards where they want to be it would
be a better system i don't want to wait
for whatever is the voting system
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com we're gonna have more
coming up at 11 p.m tonight for members
only the uncensored version which will
be a whole lot of fun we'll continue
this discussion so we've got ozzy
headshot says buckbuck yes that's right
thank you buckbuck chickens
all right
jk says we should all start calling
monkey pox jane's revenge
well okay all right
all right
storm huffman says sheamus and crew i
tried to ask you a question about
catholicism and youtube refunded my
super chat ever hear about anything like
that it's either the deep church or the
deep state that's oppressing it they
don't want you i'm kidding i i don't
know anything about that
beavis mclean says proposal tim cass
does a documentary in the spirit of matt
walsh's what is a woman when a man goes
to planned parenthood identifies as a
pregnant woman in need of an abortion to
see how far planned parenthood goes to
entertain the claim except stephen
crowder already did that several years
ago that's correct and they entertained
it all the way completely and he was
actually angry because
he said that um he was pregnant and if a
man takes a pregnancy test and it comes
back positive it typically means you
have cancer that's right and he was like
they should have told me that but they
didn't
all right
nunya business says this is for ian's
graphene revolution when are you going
to crowdfund prototypes
you know what are you doing ian uh i'll
talk i i just need a little inspiration
here guys if that's what you want me to
do if that's what you want to do if you
want to
create a graphene revolution let's do it
right on all right astral says tim do
you have any updates on when you'll drop
more music will of the people has been
on repeat every day and i'm absolutely
thirsting for more so the will of the
people album will be coming out um
mid-august
we've already got i think i think we
have 10 songs that are set to be on it
uh just today i was listening to the
drums we've got pete pirata formerly of
the offspring who's doing the drum
tracks for us
so we've got uh i think we have like 10
songs demoed out and now they're going
into full production so it's gonna be
great
and then i i think that that does i
don't think that includes will of the
people which will will be on it for its
official release we released that for
the uh just before the election in 2020
and it's just been a short film thing
that i made so if you haven't seen it
check out will of the people on youtube
it's a song and short film and uh the
actual album release with everything
will be probably mid-august and we'll do
a big ad campaign for the will of the
people album by tim cast so there you go
it's really good stuff i posted on
instagram some uh demo like small clips
of songs so you can hear them
and uh
yeah not complete mind you
all right subversive with justin
o'donnell says if democrats really cared
about roe v wade they would have used
their majorities in congress and the
senate and a democrat presidency to
codify it before the decision was
released 100 percent correct that's my
point about them not solving anything
right they don't want 100 correct that's
exactly accurate they don't solve
anything they want to make sure that
they can throw something like that
against you who would they try to codify
it i thought we talked about this
they tried to expand it but they
couldn't get the filibuster yeah
uh who was the freedom caucus guy we had
on the congressman
randy
yeah why can't i remember his name
yes sorry i think it was him but we were
told that uh when they were trying to
vote down obamacare the republicans
actually said no no no no don't vote it
down like we need the wedge issue yes
absolutely yeah exactly they're just
playing you because they wanna we're
fighting against this yeah yes then when
trump actually gets in on culture war
issues the establishment republicans are
like help us democrats and now they're
all democrats
there you go i love how the lincoln
party was like we're gonna restore the
party of lincoln and then trump loses
and they're like no we're still
democrats
it's like okay dude
oh yeah randy webber randy weber there
we go
gideon aoz says if there is a civil war
leading to two separate nations or a
peaceful divorce which side gets to keep
the name the united states of america
neither
i don't i don't think either
well it wouldn't be the united states we
would by definition not be united yeah
but if if it if it did no it'll be it
will be whatever whatever side does not
call itself the rebellion
right if if
one side is going to say they're the
rebellion the left will never call
itself the united states of america then
they won't have it then they're going to
be like this country is racist
then then they'll be the ones they're
gonna they're gonna call it like the
oppressors colonies so there we go of of
what's what's in europe no what's the
indigenous name for the flag's gonna be
them self-flagellating i'm sorry i'm
sorry
the national anthem is i'm sorry
oh i am sorry
conor brown says bill c-11 just passed
here in canada it's the internet
censorship bill and drastically limits
the media canadians can consume and
which content creators can make money
rip free speech in canada what was that
bill called c11 jeez
yeah you look it up yeah i'm looking at
it now what happened to canada
it was always a british colony and
people i know canadians get pissed at me
when i say that but i mean it's
basically part of the british
commonwealth not a comment it still is
yeah yeah it's part of it's like yes the
the the queen has her thumb on something
over there
and trudeau's just got the right to to
start taking people's guns and banning
free speech like yeah but they've never
had forever what happened you do not
have a right to defend yourself with a
gun that is not a right that canadians
have i saw a video of him when he was in
high school and he is such a smarmy
piece of crap dude
being family friendly about it wow you
are right he was when he was 18.
his dad was super famous politician so
now he got to be let's read some more
jama says what's larry's opinion of the
mises caucus taking over the libertarian
party
lpnc um the mises caucus takeover is a
symptom it's a symptom of a party that
didn't do enough to make things happen
and when the mises caucus decided to
start organizing um people came to me
and said the musicals can't even say
live will you be on advisory board i
said sure i'm happy to help you out and
then i went to other
i went to other caucuses you guys with
my help they went no
mises is bad and i said well if you want
to stop mises what you could do is
counter-organize if you think they're
bad you could always just
counter-organize and grow bigger and
better and they didn't and mises grew
and organized and
took over and i'm not complaining it is
what it is it's i think it's a normal
thing i think for the party in the long
run in the short run it's bad for me in
the short run because the civil war
libertarian body's been in has hurt me
as a as a candidate like people have
decided to not help walked away from the
party so it did hurt me when it came to
fundraising and volunteers so in the
short run it was hurtful for me but in
the long run i think it's great because
in the long run either the the the mises
caucus will do well and make the party
do do well or others will come in and
learn from them and also grow so i think
it's part of growing pains and i'm i'm
not happy about it dave smith uh 2024
i want anybody popular to include him i
would in in my perfect world it's
somebody popular because what i want in
2024 is the libertarian party to gain um
electoral votes whether that's a chunk
of nebraska whether that's utah uh part
of maine i don't care i want some gold
on that map and to make that happen we
need someone popular i would take days
with these popular absolutely i would
take anyone i would take uh
i would take drew carey he's a
libertarian i would take kurt russell
i would take uh dave smith i was like
anybody who's popular i want a popular
person uh to be running for president
will not be me by the way i'm not that
popular if i all of a sudden became
popular i would consider it but i'm not
that popular so anyone who is popular is
what i want i think that's what matters
for the party and i doubt i wouldn't
that would include dave smith for me all
right random eskimo says the writings of
the founding fathers make clear that by
well-regulated meant well-distributed
and well-provisioned regulations were
very often the records of having the
necessary supplies and abilities to
restock needs yeah regulation does not
mean what it means now which is why the
british regulars
were called that they were regulated it
doesn't mean the government was
controlling them necessarily although
you know the british crown was it meant
they were well equipped well armed and
well trained
also for that um my understanding is
paul revere never said the british are
coming that would make no sense because
they were subjects of britain he said
the regulars are coming although i don't
know i read that in like some book you
read in bathrooms
you ever see those books yeah those are
great yeah like they're made for being
in bathrooms yeah the regulars are
coming as a as a much more
valuable piece of knowledge for the
people to know because they know what
kind of enemy to be ready for like
imagine if if like
you know fbi was showing up and someone
ran by like the americans are coming
you'd be like the army's coming you're
like what do you mean is it the tanks
are coming is what you would say exactly
yes soldiers yeah
all right what do we got batman says
national guard is not the militia per
constitution the militia is forbidden
from foreign deployment while national
guard is obviously not yeah the argument
is that the militia the local militias
were uh for like
formally
molded into the national guard or
whatever but militia back then basically
meant like a bunch of local dudes who
were armed that's that's what it meant
and as long as you're well regulated
then the government has no right to
break you up
that's what that amendment is
well-regulated meant like a well-armed
you're not a mob basically like no no no
no no no no no no no you were you could
be a mob it meant you were well armed
like you had good working guns but
regulations means you're trained no
uh you're not breaking does it mean that
you're not breaking right regulated was
like no but if you if you're going with
the argument of regular like as in the
british army regulated then right to
make regular would mean to train
i i suppose theoretically but in the
terms of a bunch of farmers who have
guns i don't think the founding fathers
those are literally called the regulars
i'm talking about the mafia right what
i'm saying those are literally called
the regulars a well-regulated militia
theoretically could mean like
they weren't sending out the army to
train farmers
farmers it was just like we want them to
have guns and to know how to use them
but the but the man that was literally
withdrill
the minutemen weren't militia they were
continental army or are you talking
about i don't know
yeah the minutemen were militia yeah and
they were they literally drilled i mean
they were like they're like similar to
the once a week we come out and march
around or we do some shooting with our
guns or right we we and we ha and we
have some for them were they were they
like was were they under the command of
the continental army no they weren't but
they would they had a command structure
right you would know that the the mayor
or whoever was the person he'd be the
captain of the company but this is still
like the point i'm saying is that a
bunch of farmers who have guns and train
with them as they're at their own
discretion is very different from
trained military 100 yes but there would
be there would be some training to be a
militia there'd be some training you
have to show up once a month or whatever
the thing is march around and learn how
to use your weapons but that's like you
and you and your neighbors being like
hey on friday the third friday we're all
gonna go out shooting it back all right
yeah but it's probably different but it
probably would have been something that
was that would be official
right like the mayor would say hey you
can use the the parade grounds on ev
every thursday or something like that
but but my point is when it was official
you're talking about a town of like a
hundred people or something small yeah
so we got to separate them from the
context of today we have a mayor of a
town of three hundred thousand you
understand before calling people to come
out different world my point is
basically it was like you and your
neighbors going out and
you know some guy with 50 acres being
like you guys can use my land if you
want to go shooting which still happens
today yeah
all right
all right let's see let's grab some more
a lot of second amendment ones which we
i think i think we addressed a lot of
we beat that one down a bit yeah
all right uh what do we got here
charles juan says they don't care they
won't debate they don't want a
conversation they want a tyrannical
government to force their beliefs on you
and your children but who are they
who are they
uh i think he's talking about leftists i
want names
i want names it's good
all right
dragon
dragon's talon says district of columbia
v heller the supreme court held that the
second amendment protects the individual
right to possess a firearm unconnected
with service in a militia
right and then donald v chicago was this
right extends to all states not just
federal the federal government and so
all of a sudden in chicago everybody was
buying guns and they were the city was
freaking out and they were angry about
it
now what we need is for the supreme
court to say
requiring permission from the government
is an infringement upon your right to
keep and bear arms and then permits are
gone
no more permits everybody just have a
gun go buy one and body armor too well
new york didn't didn't just ban bodies
why yeah because again we'll just do
things because we'll take action on
things that make no sense whatsoever and
how do they define body armor
probably stupidly yeah it's my
assumption because
you know yes i have a phone in my pocket
that's body armor put them in jail i'm
sure that's what they'll they'll say you
know what they were doing in thailand is
they were taking sheets of x-ray x-ray
film layering it and then putting it in
the uh tactical vests to hold because it
provided some protection particularly
from blunt force objects
they argued it could stop some rounds
but probably not rifle rounds but they
swore by it that body armor yeah no no
the worst part is in buffalo which was
our our shooting the the only guy who
stood up right because he was there was
one armed guy there at the actual uh
supermarket he was a former cop
um he turned and fired the kitty hit
didn't go down because the kid had body
armor and the kid put him down because
he didn't
so now what our answer is to make sure
guys that came will never have body
armor i don't know how that makes any
sense but that's what we've done in new
york tony t says ian if they strip the
right to keep and bear arms the people
cannot create a well-regulated militia
to fight enemies both foreign and
domestic it would just be a protest at
that point yeah but i also regardless of
whether or not they're armed i think
that a militia has a right to form
yeah
before police they had militia
and then i was reading about the history
of police because the left likes to push
this lie that police are the remnants of
slave catchers and it's like actually
yeah sometimes but typically no but they
also think everything's the remnant of
slavery right yeah most police
departments were just an expansion of
local law enforcement sheriffs and
deputies and stuff and they were like
hey we need something like this but like
you know in the city and they're like
okay and it was i think it was done in
france first
and then uh yeah before that a lot of
areas just have a militia and they'd
catch somebody and they'd bring them to
the sheriff or whatever or the courts
would deal with it
free golem says red flag laws equals
state-sanctioned swatting yes that is
correct correct very true
cody bridger says the constitution is
not poorly written ian is poorly read
i don't know i mean it is 250 year old
document we could probably update it i
actually got to say i don't know if it's
that it's poorly written other than the
fact that language changes yes and you
have uh what is it the textualists
versus what's the other phrase
like the people who read it verbatim by
text the supreme court justices versus
those who like interpret what they think
it's supposed to mean modernist i don't
know no no that's the originalists
originalists yeah yeah yeah absolutely
the textualists are the bad ones they're
like well it says well-regulated that
means the government has to control it
and then the originalists are like no
that's not that's not what regular meant
back then regulation is it it has a
different meaning now than it had that
then it literally meant to make regular
versus now it means to control
justin clark says in modern colloquial
english 2a is quote because a
well-regulated militia is necessary to
the security of a free state the right
of the people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed
and that's basically where we're at
right now at the supreme court and how
they see it and i'm hoping i just want
him to go nuts i want i want to see like
i don't know alito or thomas just with
their their you know glowing red eyes
just drop the opinion and it says like
everyone gets guns
period
yeah
i'm half kidding by the way i think if
people want to change the rules you have
to get the amen you have to get the
amendments in so when people are like we
should ban this i'm like by all means
get the votes to amend the constitution
the purpose of the constitution and the
reason it exists as it is and if you
want to amend it it's very difficult is
because democracy is two wolves in a
sheep deciding on what's for lunch but a
republic is a well-armed sheep
contesting the vote so you don't you do
not get to take away my right to keep
and bear arms because you don't like it
even if you're in the majority sorry
too
bad all right
daniel brent says having a blm flag a
confederate flag what if i flew a
literal red flag could that reporter
that felt intimidated by the amer by
american flags call them in this will
hopefully get shot down in the courts
which one is that a reference to
i don't know the communist
comments is that what they want the red
flag i don't know
dim sum nimsam says there is a rating
system caliber and grain weight two f
bill maher he wanted recession to get
rid of trump he got what he asked for he
doesn't get to complain now
yeah um that's about the point it's
about the point yeah
i like that he calls out the wokeness
the absurdity yeah i don't like that
he's a lead he's elitist he's snooty and
he's not well read at all i'm just
trying to say when when someone like him
who is a a person who many people look
at and see
when he does something right let's not
attack him let's reward that good
behavior
all i'm saying and i think that is one
of the strengths that the right for all
of its present weaknesses still has
which is that when somebody says
something good we go oh that was good
instead of going they did something good
let's find something they said 10 years
ago to cancel them with right very good
that said we don't want to welcome them
into the movement and say this guy's a
conservative when he's been literally
against us his entire life but yes when
someone does something good acknowledge
it was good totally agree yes
all right twitchy spaz says tim you
should invite philip defranco on the
show he used to be center right but has
fallen into leftist ideology he's about
having a conversation but he has nothing
but leftist conversation uh phil would
be absolutely welcome on this show yeah
i don't know what he's up to i know that
he got the last time i heard him he got
covington wrong he came out against the
covington kids and like on
yeah i don't really pay attention to
what he would you know what he's been
doing other than that i just mean like
that's the one thing where people are
like very critical of him do you
apologize for that i don't know i'd
assume he did i don't think he's a bad
dude but i remember he didn't he
interviewed gary johnson or he did
something with the libertarian party
back in like 2012 on youtube interesting
yeah youtube i don't remember that
he's always been really politically
engaged since like oh six i've known him
way way way back when he was just uh
sexy phil sxe straight edge phil yeah
black and white oh that's that's what
that was xe means straight edge sexy
phil you ever hear his old theme song
intro check it out look it looks like
youtube he's not sexy
sexy phil he's ass
a murray says right wing is
individualism the left is collectivism
libertarians are default right
that's one of a million ways to look at
it i think that's the modern definition
i think that's the modern definition i
would say conservative is family-based
but [ __ ] more individualism and then
leftism is more collectivism i think
that's a more robust way of defining it
but you're right it's a present cultural
better way of saying it it's a better
way but in the present cultural context
that is true i mean that is how it is
viewed today
a free thinking dog says conservatism
equals preservation of original intent
and that is individual liberty and
self-governance selfish individuals have
ruined the great experiment
or the great experiment this is a part
of it it's ungovernable right now
because over 700 000 people are
represented by one yes that's incapable
it's nonsense yep yeah and then you look
at uh so you had flores i think was it
flores myra flores yeah she won in that
special election in texas texas yeah and
everyone's like red wave they're like
this proves it she's like it's a
landslide like twice as many votes and
i'm like bro 28 000 people voted right
yeah like i think 20 000 people vote for
her like 14 for the other guy in a
district of 700 000 right a special
election is not indicative of of what is
going to happen when you get 200 000
people voting right however i do think
there is some data to extrapolate the
people who pay attention voted yeah
that's true the people who pay attention
are going to come out and vote but if
the people who pay attention are only 14
000 people i don't think they'll move
the needle all that much come the
general election well this was back to
what you were talking about right what
most them want to do is they want to
keep
a culture war issue that's not
solved to get the people who aren't
paying attention to vote blindly for
them
right so
if i am trying to get people blind left
a blind right i pick a cultural war
issue and go you got to stop this thing
so come on out and vote me because of
this thing that's so dangerous it's like
playing with fire yes and the sparks fly
and they can catch stuff
this is why it's ruining us that's
exactly right you're correct yes so i
yell at i say look if you want to make
sure that a woman will have a right to
an abortion you have to come out and
vote right you say that oh my god and
then people who feel that way who aren't
paying attention go oh yes i i i like
women i'm not anti-woman they go that
and they run out and they vote and they
vote for the other guy or what works
even better is you just put trump on the
ballot
you put nothing motivates the left to
come out more than hatred of trump so
yeah you put trump on the ballot and the
left comes out and votes that's why i
think it was robert barnes who was
saying this they're not going to indict
trump they're not going to do a criminal
referral because if trump gets indicted
then you get rhonda santos and he wins
on a landslide
yep let's go i agree
i agree i've been thinking about it and
my my concern is i don't think ron
desantis is going to drain the swamp i
think he's going to try and just
simmer things down but do right i think
i think he'll want to do the right thing
but he's going to try to avoid
i think he's going to make similar
mistakes that trump made if trump got in
now he would just be a ball in a china
shop he'd be firing everybody left and
right he'd be gutting systems he'd be
just i don't know man it's like he
didn't do it last time but this time
he's gonna be different yeah i just
don't see it he didn't do it last time
and they destroyed him and now he's
angry
but anger doesn't get you there it's not
anger that gets good personnel decisions
made no i'm not talking about good
personal decisions i'm talking about him
just firing people who made him angry
but who's he going to replace it with i
don't care out of angers or some idiot i
don't care the executive branch has
expanded its authority to an absurd
degree relentlessly absolutely true i
don't care oh my god i don't know how
much power one guy has to disrupt that
you've got an administrative state that
has no accountability and if trump just
went and fired him i'd be happy rhonda
sanchez probably won't
but i like desantis he's more
professional he's got military
experience he can probably get a lot
done i'm just wondering if
then four years later the administrative
state just carries on the way it always
does the first i've heard the status on
foreign policy i'm not convinced what's
up with his uh his military experiences
i saw he was in the navy maybe and he
served at guantanamo i i don't know much
about it
i don't know about that i just saw an
article about it and yeah i've heard
that he did something with the uh with
the israeli foreign policy about what
was this where you don't don't insult
israel that the bs is a bsd let's let's
read it let's read a couple more so
because we get to the members only we've
got dirk tanino says the attempt to
alter language to undermine legal and
cultural norms is a constant consistent
tactic that can be seen in most if not
all identitarian cover labels feminism
blm etc until they move on to an
untainted label yep
yeah and it's like i i think that's it's
in communist countries they do the same
thing yeah you can it's uh you control
the the language the movement i was
mentioning is boycott divestment and
sanctions bds i don't know what what um
interesting you don't want to do any
business at all this the government will
not do any business at all with israel
let's uh we'll we have this run more one
more super chat john curry says heller
and mcdonald protect body armor read it
very interesting new york's in for some
some lawsuits
so we will see my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
share the show anywhere you can head
over to timcast.com and become a member
because we're going to have a members
only show coming up at 11 p.m we do that
monday through thursday they are
uncensored and you don't want to miss it
as a member you're helping support the
expansion we've got a couple
documentaries in the works we're doing
one on gun control we're doing one on
the federal reserve that's the plan for
now we are launching we've got we've got
pop culture crisis of course we've got a
couple new shows we're planning on
launching everything is going amazing
it's all thanks to you so help continue
that operation you can follow the show
at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast larry you want to
shout anything out absolutely guys i'm
running for governor and i need help
taking care of my petitioners i need
help with all i'm getting double lawsuit
i'm getting sued by the republican party
in my state to get me off the ballot and
i'm going to be in court twice and i
need help for that guys if you want to
help me out with that you can go to
lpny.org
head on down there and donate they will
help to take care of the lawsuits and
petitioners you want to support me
directly
larrysharp.com don't forget that's
lottery shop with an e
and the e stands for electable
all right there you go
a lot of foresight on your your parents
part to make sure that they would have
that they knew that
my parents were thinking this child will
be electable there's one thing he is um
i'm shameless cognitive i want to make a
quick identity with something early we
we're talking about ross pro i said i
liked him i'm not a fan i liked sort of
what he did with renting a spot on
television talking about the deficit i
thought that was cool um but overall not
a fan uh sheamus coughlin
freedomtunes.com if you guys want to go
over there all right five bucks a month
you'll get an extra cartoon every week
there we have like seven cartoons up
there right now you'll love them and uh
we're gonna be releasing a new cartoon
on the freedom tunes channel this
thursday i think you all will enjoy it
so go over there subscribe i want to
shout out lucardkowski and we are change
i believe it's we are change.com i don't
know luke what's your website right now
we are change.org dot org and you can
check it out on youtube there's not much
in life that feels better than enhancing
your friends so do it see you later
i am also here thank you guys very much
for tuning in i enjoyed this
conversation with larry as we always do
you guys may follow me on twitter and
mines.com at sarapatrics as well as
sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you